How are you? It's exciting. Was getting in okay? Or was there a cavity search? There was a cavity search and it was good. Wasn't long enough, actually. And Sean went back for seconds. And they said, we don't, we never had anybody come back for a second.
你好吗？太令人兴奋了。进来还顺利吗？还是被搜身了？确实被搜身了，而且感觉不错。其实时间还不够长。肖恩还回去排了第二次队。他们说，我们从来没见过有人回来排第二次队的。
You're good. It's not Thanksgiving. You're clean. He said, can I come back tomorrow to get cold leftovers? Welcome to the show. giving. You're clean. Yeah. He said, could I come back tomorrow to get cold leftovers? Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Blast. Guys, take a breath and think about what this is about to be.
你表现得很好。又不是感恩节。你很干净。他说，我明天能回来吃冷剩菜吗？欢迎来到节目。你很干净。是的。他说，我明天能回来吃冷剩菜吗？欢迎来到《Smartless》。Smart。Blast。伙计们，深呼吸，想想这即将发生的是什么。
It's fucking insane, you guys. Yeah. Oh, we're rolling. It's insane. Do you guys have good questions? I have a couple. Sort of. I have areas. Wait, wait, and not prep. I did prep.
这简直太疯狂了，伙计们。是的。哦，我们开始录了。这太疯狂了。你们有好的问题吗？我有几个。算是吧。我有几个方向。等等，等等，不是准备好的。我准备了。
I did, I thought... I had a lot of conversations with people. I've got 18 questions. Oh good, I'll just follow you. I was not joking when I said, I think it's good that we have questions, but I also want to entertain conversation and listening. Let's just make it a conversation.
我准备了，我想……我和很多人聊过。我有18个问题。哦，很好，我就跟着你走。我说我们有准备问题是好事，但我同时也想让对话和倾听变得有趣，我这话不是开玩笑的。我们就把它变成一场对话吧。
And through conversation, questions will come out. Is that right? I think so. Oh boy. So how are you guys feeling when you woke up today knowing that this is gonna happen? Are we recording right now? Yeah. Yeah. Are we really? Yeah. Oh. So this is a whole different... I gotta put on my radio voice. We can say where we are because it's... After the fact, yeah. So we're here... Don't say it! No, I'm kidding. Well we're here on Central Park South
通过对话，问题自然会浮现出来。对吧？我想是这样。天哪。那么，当你们今天醒来知道这件事要发生时，你们感觉如何？我们现在在录音吗？是的。是的。真的吗？是的。哦。所以这是一个完全不同的……我得用我的广播腔说话了。我们可以说我们在哪里，因为这是……事后录的，是的。所以我们在这里……别说出来！不，我开玩笑的。我们是在中央公园南。
with a beautiful second story view of the park. If second story is beautiful views. Little rainy. Tree tops is nice. Little rainy. And we very rarely have more than one guest. Sometimes we have two. When were the times we did it? We had...
这里有美丽的二楼景观，可以看到公园。如果二楼算美丽景观的话。有点下雨。树顶很漂亮。有点下雨。我们很少有超过一位嘉宾。有时我们会有两位。我们什么时候做过？我们有……
When you have bands on, a lot of times we have two. Like Billie Eilish and Finn. Yeah. Radiohead. Radio Billie Eilish and Finn. Yeah, Radiohead. Radiohead. Yeah, we had. Duran Duran. Killers.
当你们请乐队来的时候，很多时候我们会有两位。比如比莉·艾利什和芬。是的。电台司令。电台比莉·艾利什和芬。是的，电台司令。电台司令。是的，我们请过。杜兰杜兰乐队。杀手乐队。
Oh no, that was just Simon. Duran, Duran. The Killers. The Killers, the Pesh Mode. Oh, the Killers, the Pesh Mode, right. That was great. And so today we're doing a first time, it's a little risky, there's three of them.
哦不，那次只有西蒙。杜兰，杜兰。杀手乐队。杀手乐队，赶时髦乐队。哦，杀手乐队，赶时髦乐队，对。那太棒了。所以今天我们是第一次尝试，有点冒险，有三位嘉宾。
But it's kind of a band full of rock stars. Bear with us. Yeah, yeah, they're like the police. Yeah. So you'll be familiar with one of them. The other two he wanted to bring along, I guess his buddies. He gets a little nervous. We've had him on the show before.
但这就像是一个摇滚明星组成的乐队。请多包涵。是的，是的，他们就像警察乐队。是的。所以你们会熟悉其中一位。另外两位是他想带来的，我想是他的哥们儿。他有点紧张。我们之前请过他上节目。
He wanted to do it again. They're guys he worked with, I guess. Yeah, we don't really do repeat guests, but we made an exception here. And we certainly don't let people bring buddies, but he was insistent. Can I just say, I'm excited too, and can I just say, we're sitting here in this hotel room, as we've already said.
他想再来一次。我想他们是他一起工作过的人。是的，我们通常不请重复的嘉宾，但这次我们破例了。而且我们肯定不让人们带哥们儿来，但他坚持要带。我能说我也很兴奋吗？我能说我们正坐在这个酒店房间里，正如我们已经说过的。
It's 2024, four years ago, less than four years ago, we started doing this podcast, it was a COVID baby, as we call it. It came out of the gate with Dax Shepard. It came out of the gate with Dax Shepard, which was great. But I set the bar high with Dax. And then now here we are in New York. Four years later, scraping the bottom of the barrel.
现在是2024年，不到四年前，我们开始做这个播客，它是我们所谓的“新冠宝宝”。它刚开始时请到了戴克斯·夏普德。它刚开始时请到了戴克斯·夏普德，这很棒。但我把门槛设得很高，因为有戴克斯。然后现在我们来到了纽约。四年后，我们在捡破烂。
We're looking at it with a dude and his buddies. We got Rob Armjarve. And we got Bennett Barbecao. And we got MGT, Michael the G. Terry, and we're all here in New York and it's fucking wild, guys. And I want to say to you guys, this is cool, this is one of those life moments, right?
我们正看着一个家伙和他的哥们儿。我们有罗伯·阿姆贾夫。我们有贝内特·巴贝考。我们有MGT，迈克尔·G·特里，我们都在纽约，这太疯狂了，伙计们。我想对你们说，这很酷，这是人生中的那些时刻之一，对吧？
You got to stop and like recognize it. Michael, I just want to say, Michael, how's it for you? Delightful. Delightful. That's it. Delightful, and I'm proud of us, we haven't screwed it up yet. Bennett, what do you think?ightful. Delightful. That's it. Delightful. And I'm proud of us, we haven't screwed it up yet. Bennett, what do you think?
你得停下来，好好感受一下。迈克尔，我只想说，迈克尔，你感觉如何？令人愉悦。令人愉悦。就是这样。令人愉悦，我为我们感到骄傲，我们还没搞砸。贝内特，你怎么看？令人愉悦。令人愉悦。就是这样。令人愉悦。我为我们感到骄傲，我们还没搞砸。贝内特，你怎么看？
It feels... It's amazing. It's weird, right? Wow, these adjectives are incredible. We've been saying to take a breath. Rob, Rob, yell something from over there. How are you feeling? Fantastic!
感觉……太棒了。很奇怪，对吧？哇，这些形容词真是不可思议。我们一直在说要深呼吸。罗伯，罗伯，在那边喊点什么。你感觉如何？太棒了！
Ah, that's Rob. Rob has got amazing... We did limit them each to one word. Yeah, and Rob doesn't even have a microphone. So thank you for your contributions. We have been reminding ourselves to be present though and take a breath and take a look at it. It's pretty cool.
啊，那是罗伯。罗伯有惊人的……我们确实限制他们每人只能说一个词。是的，而且罗伯甚至没有麦克风。所以谢谢你们的贡献。不过我们一直在提醒自己要活在当下，深呼吸，好好看看这一切。这真的很酷。
Now, Will came up to get a ride with my guy that I sometimes hire for like when I do a Broadway show. Who drove it when he was doing, you know Sean did a play on Broadway last year? No. Yeah. And it was called, you know Sean did a play on Broadway last year? No. Yeah. And it was called Go Get Me Oscar, I think. Right.
刚才，威尔过来搭我雇的人的车，我有时做百老汇演出时会雇他。肖恩去年在百老汇演戏时是谁开的车？不。是的。那部戏叫，你知道肖恩去年在百老汇演戏吗？不。是的。那部戏叫《去帮我找奥斯卡》，我想。对。
Right, or. And it was, wasn't it at the, wasn't it with the Topo Chico. The Topo Chico Theater. Yeah. And. Yeah, and so he came, so Will, I said do you wanna ride, because I think Jason's close, really close to the hotel. So Will came straight so Will, I said, do you want to ride? Because I think Jason's really close to the hotel. So Will came straight up.
对，或者。那是，不是在那个，不是在Topo Chico剧院吗？Topo Chico剧院。是的。而且。是的，所以他来了，所以威尔，我说你想搭车吗，因为我觉得杰森离酒店很近，真的很近。所以威尔直接来了，所以威尔，我说，你想搭车吗？因为我觉得杰森离酒店真的很近。所以威尔直接过来了。
The first thing, I put my pants on and I walked out to the living room with my shirt and my pants on. I reached in my pocket and I found money. I found like 30 bucks. Great story. But here's the best part. Sean pulls out and he turns to Scotty and he goes, look at this.
第一件事，我穿上裤子，穿着衬衫和裤子走到客厅。我伸手进兜里，发现有钱。我发现了大概30块钱。好故事。但最棒的部分在这里。肖恩掏出来，转向斯科蒂说，看这个。
And we go, what? He goes, he's got like $31. He goes, look at all this money. And we go, yeah. And he goes he's got like $31. He goes, look at all this money. And we go, yeah. And he go, so the pants are clean. Obviously today's a big event for you. Yeah, exactly. So the dry cleaner's just, dry cleaner's just.
我们问，什么？他说，他有大概31块钱。他说，看这些钱。我们说，是的。他说，他有大概31块钱。他说，看这些钱。我们说，是的。他说，所以裤子是干净的。显然今天对你来说是个大日子。是的，没错。所以干洗店只是，干洗店只是。
I haven't been here for six months. I just put these pants on. And I was like, oh, I guess I wore them out. And there was just the one pair of socks that you stole from a youngster you were babysitting? I know, you don't know where the skin ends and the sock starts. You know, it's fairly high class guests today. You didn't think you'd go with a full length sock.
我六个月没来这儿了。我刚穿上这条裤子。我就想，哦，我猜我穿过它们。还有你从一个你照看的孩子那里偷来的那双袜子？我知道，你分不清哪里是皮肤，哪里是袜子。你知道，今天的嘉宾档次相当高。你没想到你会穿长筒袜。
And Will doesn't have socks at all. I know, but that's the way to go. I know, I should have gone full length. Shani, what do you decide? How do you decide what clothes stay here in your apartment in New York? What's the math that you do on that? I don't, I just, you know, there's like a couple t-shirts and clearly a couple pants and I mean pants is a stretch They're jeans. No, they're not their pants. Sorry. They're a stretch
威尔根本没穿袜子。我知道，但那是最好的选择。我知道，我应该穿长筒袜的。沙尼，你决定了吗？你如何决定哪些衣服留在纽约的公寓里？你用的什么算法？我不，我只是，你知道，有几件T恤，显然还有几条裤子，我是说裤子有点勉强，那是牛仔裤。不，不是，那是裤子。抱歉。那是勉强。
They look like they're dress pants. They're a brushed cotton jegging. Yes. Thank you But they're in a five-pin cut Jason's in corduroys and a and a yeah But Jason I mean Jason looks like he's doing a whole different... But I'm also living here and I don't have, you know, President of the United States clothes with me. Yeah, yeah. You know? You look good.
它们看起来像正装裤。那是拉绒棉紧身裤。是的。谢谢。但它们是五袋剪裁。杰森穿着灯芯绒裤子，还有一件，还有一件，是的。但杰森，我是说杰森看起来像是完全不同的……但我住在这里，我没有，你知道，美国总统穿的那种衣服。是的，是的。你知道吗？你看起来不错。
I said before, you look very rugged and sexy. Thank you very much. I'm playing a guy that's made a lot of bad decisions. You know what I like about your hair is long enough that when you're wearing the headphones right now, it's keeping the hair back and you've got kind of like a soccer, like a European soccer player vibe going on. He's slowly winking at you. And the slow winks we could do without.
我之前说过，你看起来非常粗犷性感。非常感谢。我演的是一个做了很多错误决定的人。你知道我喜欢你头发的哪一点吗？它够长，当你现在戴着耳机时，它能把头发往后压，你有一种，就像欧洲足球运动员的那种气质。他在慢慢地对你眨眼。那些慢动作眨眼我们还是免了吧。
And they're half winks too. They're more lid squeezes. That's so gross. So you guys have... Do you have important questions loaded? Do you have fun questions loaded? I have a little bit of both. A little bit of both. You've got some important questions loaded? Do you have fun questions loaded? I have a little bit of both.
而且那是半眨眼。更像是眼皮挤压。太恶心了。所以你们有……你们准备了重要的问题吗？你们准备了有趣的问题吗？我两者都有。两者都有。你们准备了一些重要的问题吗？你们准备了有趣的问题吗？我两者都有。
A little bit of both. You've got some policy questions perhaps? Yeah, mine obviously have more to do with relations with Canada. Sure. Right? Sure. Is that one of the borders we're closing? I hope not.
两者都有。你们准备了一些政策问题吗？是的，我的显然更多是关于与加拿大的关系。当然。对吧？当然。那是我们要关闭的边境之一吗？我希望不是。
You know, because how are we going to get all our stuff across, eh? I'm still moving cigarettes. Fuck, I don't care. I'm mulling some of that sticky BC bud through the interior. I'm coming down through Fernie, BC, eh? My brother found a good path last year. Let's see what they have to say about that. Sure, I want to hear what they have to say. Yeah, I wonder, I'm sure they don't want to get into the micro of policy and stuff like that.
你知道，因为我们要怎么把我们的东西运过去，嗯？我还在运香烟。去他的，我不在乎。我正在把一些粘性的BC大麻通过内陆运过去。我正从BC省的弗尼下来，嗯？我兄弟去年发现了一条好路。看看他们对此怎么说。当然，我想听听他们怎么说。是的，我想，我肯定他们不想深入讨论政策之类的细节。
They're not, they're, I'm sure they would, they'd like us to find a middle ground between drive time radio and some hard-hitting meet the press conversation. Yeah, but I mean, I can't, I don't know how to formulate those questions. Well, you know what's interesting is that the three of them obviously are very connected and they they're all sort of from the the same sort of class Of Democrats in that right that they they were around Obama was a rising star You know President Biden's been around since the 70s Senator, etc
他们不是，他们，我肯定他们希望我们在开车时听的广播和那种尖锐的《会见媒体》对话之间找到一个中间地带。是的，但我，我不知道怎么组织那些问题。嗯，你知道有趣的是，他们三个人显然联系非常紧密，他们都属于同一种，同一种民主党人，对吧？他们都在奥巴马成为一颗冉冉升起的新星时就在那里。你知道，拜登总统从70年代就在那里了，参议员等等。
Obama came up as this young star in the early 2000s Nobody will forget his fiery speech at the Democratic Convention in 2004. How amazing that was. So they're all part of the same. Clinton was a governor and, yeah. Clinton was a governor and then he was a superstar back to back. Arkansas, right?
奥巴马在2000年代初作为一颗年轻的新星出现。没人会忘记他在2004年民主党大会上那场激昂的演讲。那太棒了。所以他们都是同一类人。克林顿曾是州长，而且，是的。克林顿曾是州长，然后他连续两次成为超级巨星。阿肯色州，对吧？
Yes, Arkansas, good, Sean. Thank you. But back to back of President of the United States. So they all, I think, have very, they're similar, my point is they're similarly minded when it comes to sort of policy. Yeah, yeah, for sure. Et cetera. Well, it's cool that they all are together.
是的，阿肯色州，很好，肖恩。谢谢。但连续两次担任美国总统。所以我认为他们都有非常，他们很相似，我的意思是他们在政策方面想法相似。是的，是的，当然。等等。嗯，他们都在一起真是太酷了。
I don't know that I've ever seen that or witnessed that. Yeah, I mean, I don't even see George W. and his dad together. Didn't they? But didn't the three of them get together for the last election a bit? Didn't they sort of?
我不知道我是否见过或见证过这种情况。是的，我的意思是，我甚至没见过乔治·W·布什和他父亲在一起。他们没在一起吗？但他们三个人在上次选举时不是聚在一起过吗？他们不是有点……
You're thinking of the three tenors, I think. These are not... By the way, we have to do them. We don't do the three tenors right after this. I quit. We should just start, let's start the interview mistaking them for the three tenors. So when do you guys, have you been in rehearsals long? Because the Radio City show tonight should be getting
你想到的是“三大男高音”，我想。这些不是……顺便说一下，我们必须做他们。我们不能在这一段之后做“三大男高音”。我不干了。我们应该直接开始，让我们把采访开始，把他们误认为是“三大男高音”。所以你们排练多久了？因为今晚的无线电城演出应该会……
the acoustics. We're so excited for the sound. What's your warm up like? Will there be solos or do you guys just sing all the songs together? You guys are slimmer than I remember opera singers. And your accents are fantastic. Really tremendous.
音响效果。我们对声音太兴奋了。你们的热身是什么样的？会有独唱吗，还是你们一起唱所有的歌？你们比我记忆中的歌剧演员要苗条。而且你们的口音太棒了。真的非常了不起。
Yeah, exactly. Well guys, I'm honored to be here, not just with them, I'm honored to be here with you guys. Likewise. This is an eventous occasion, not just in the podcast, but in life. Yes. Tell me your name. And I'm sorry, be here with you guys. This is a tremendous occasion, not just in the podcast, but in life. Yes, tell me your name. And I'm sorry, it's Will, it's still Will.
是的，没错。好吧，伙计们，我很荣幸能在这里，不仅是和他们在一起，我很荣幸能和你们在一起。同样。这是一个重大的时刻，不仅是在播客中，而且在生活中。是的。告诉我你的名字。抱歉，能和你们在一起。这是一个重大的时刻，不仅是在播客中，而且在生活中。是的，告诉我你的名字。抱歉，是威尔，还是威尔。
And I'm really psyched that I get to be here with you guys during this. Likewise. It's not lost on me, not to pat ourselves on the back, but just to say briefly, very proud of us that we haven't screwed this up yet, and that Mr. Biden called us again Yeah, and wanted to do this again wanted to bring his friend like it was just so so flattered and humbled and yeah
我真的很兴奋能在这期间和你们在一起。同样。我没有忘记，不是为了自夸，只是简单地说，非常为我们感到骄傲，我们还没搞砸，而且拜登先生又给我们打电话了，是的，还想再做一次，还想带他的朋友来，这真是太受宠若惊，太谦卑了，是的。
Yeah, that's it's crazy. Did oh to all of it. Here we go. It's a it's an all-new super presidential Smartless Oh, smartless. All right, I'm over there, right? We're just gonna come in and adjust the microphones, too. You're welcome. Yeah, thank you. So headphones on, yeah? Yeah, headset's on. So, can you grab those headphones right there, please?
是的，这太疯狂了。对所有这一切。我们开始吧。这是一个全新的超级总统版《Smartless》。哦，Smartless。好了，我在那边，对吧？我们也要进来调整麦克风。不客气。是的，谢谢。所以戴上耳机，对吧？是的，耳机戴上了。那么，能帮我拿一下那边的耳机吗，拜托？
Okay. And I'm gonna swing this in a little bit. Ah. Thank you, sir. You're welcome. Mr. Clinton, have you done any time, Mr. Clinton, in Lake of the Ozarks? Oh, yeah. Right?
好的。我要把它稍微转过来。啊。谢谢你，先生。不客气。克林顿先生，你在欧扎克湖待过一段时间吗，克林顿先生？哦，是的。对吧？
Because that was just, that's in your neck of the old woods there. Yeah. I spent a lot of time. I've been to every voting precincts in the Northern Arkansas Ozarks, and I have, I had one of the presidents of Walmart sure came from a little town In the Ozarks near the lake of the Ozarks and I went up they had a day for him I don't want up there once I can hear fine. Okay, so I've most around up there Oh good, but was that whatever a vacation spot for you?
因为那就在你那片老林子附近。是的。我花了很多时间。我去过北阿肯色州欧扎克的所有投票区，而且我，我有一位沃尔玛的总裁确实来自欧扎克湖附近的一个小镇，我上去过，他们为他举办了一天活动，我不想上去一次，我听得清楚。好的，所以我大部分时间都在那儿。哦，很好，但那是你的度假胜地吗？
No, I didn't take any vacations up there. I was working up there, but I was up there all the time. Here's your home with beach tiller. That's a big spot for folks in that part of the country. Oh yeah, it's breathtakingly beautiful. Yeah, yeah, that lake gets a lot of work. Judging by your show, Jason, seems like a pretty dangerous part of the world, too. Well, we didn't really spend a lot of time in there.
不，我没在那儿度过假。我在那儿工作，但我一直都在那儿。这是你的家，海滩耕耘者。那是那个国家那部分地区人们的大地方。哦，是的，美得令人窒息。是的，是的，那个湖有很多工作。从你的节目来看，杰森，那似乎也是世界上一个相当危险的地方。嗯，我们没在那儿花太多时间。
Yeah, we didn't spend a lot of time with the nice part. Not much of a show in that. My family vacationed there once when I was a kid, and everybody got drunk. What a surprise. I still remember when it was all illegal. We had a sheriff from up there that had a jail where the cells were all below level.
是的，我们没在好的部分花太多时间。那没什么看头。我小时候家人在那里度假过一次，每个人都喝醉了。真令人惊讶。我还记得当它还是非法的时候。我们那里有个警长，他有个监狱，牢房都在水平面以下。
Below the water level? No, below ground level. So they were all pot forms. Uh-huh. When it was all still illegal. He made a hell of a lot of money doing it. That's crazy. Is it legal in Missouri and Arkansas yet?
在水位以下？不，在地下。所以它们都是坑。嗯哼。当一切还是非法的时候。他靠这个赚了一大笔钱。这太疯狂了。在密苏里州和阿肯色州合法了吗？
Are you planning a trip? Sort of. But when it's all illegal. He did it. But I think... You basically scout out every state. It's like, can I go here, is this okay? Well it's a sequel, you know, we've done the old.
你在计划旅行吗？算是吧。但当一切还是非法的时候。他做到了。但我认为……你基本上侦察了每一个州。就像，我可以去这里吗，这可以吗？嗯，这是续集，你知道，我们做过旧的。
Funny, we're going to Missouri. It was more fun when it was illegal. Uh huh, yeah, exactly. Well, I love doing it. You should have had me writing some of your scripts for you. I was gonna help you. I wanna start by, you know, first of all, this is huge for us.
有趣，我们要去密苏里州。它在非法的时候更有趣。嗯哼，是的，没错。嗯，我喜欢做这个。你应该让我帮你写一些剧本。我本来要帮你的。我想先，你知道，首先，这对我们来说意义重大。
And what a massive honor it is to be sitting with the three of you looking at us. It's so bizarre. Crazy. We're wondering. We're all wondering how we ended up here. I'm sure. You've got questions for your staff. And your questions are only going to grow as to why you did it, as we get into it.
能和你们三位坐在一起看着我们，这是多么巨大的荣幸。太离奇了。疯狂。我们很好奇。我们都在想我们是怎么走到这一步的。我肯定。你有给员工的问题。随着我们深入，你对为什么要这么做的疑问只会越来越多。
And we were saying earlier, four years ago, we started this podcast during COVID as a way to kind of connect with each other. And we ended up connecting with a lot of people out there. And for us, it's a real thrill to be here. Did you ever get Trump? Uh, we- Couldn't make his deal. No, we're letting other people get him.
我们之前说过，四年前，我们在新冠期间开始了这个播客，作为一种相互联系的方式。我们最终与外面的很多人建立了联系。对我们来说，能在这里真是太激动了。你们请到特朗普了吗？呃，我们……没谈成。不，我们让别人去请他。
Yeah. Well done, Will. Thank you. Very bravo, bravo. But it is, it is momentous for us, and especially during this time that we're in right now, to have your time, so we thank you for your time. Yeah, yeah, yeah, this is huge.
是的。做得好，威尔。谢谢。非常棒，棒极了。但这确实，这对我们来说意义重大，特别是在我们现在所处的这个时期，能占用你们的时间，所以我们感谢你们的时间。是的，是的，是的，这太重要了。
How do you all know each other? I'm kidding. That was my opening. But it is, I mean. I've worked for both of them a long time. Yeah, I know, I know. It's not the first time that you three have combined forces to really kind of
你们是怎么认识的？我开玩笑的。那是我的开场白。但这确实，我的意思是。我为他们俩工作了很长时间。是的，我知道，我知道。这不是你们三个人第一次联手来真正地……
do what we all need you guys to do, which is keep you in office. But does it strike you as like, how is it even necessary to have half a president campaigning against the other guy? It is shocking to me that it takes the amount of effort to be competitive against someone who just, in my opinion, is just running for the wrong thing. Well, lots changed. Lots changed in how you communicate. Lots changed in information
做我们所有人都需要你们做的事情，那就是让你们留在办公室。但这是否让你觉得，让半个总统去反对另一个人竞选怎么会有必要呢？让我感到震惊的是，要与一个在我看来只是为了错误的事情而竞选的人竞争，需要付出这么大的努力。嗯，很多事情变了。在沟通方式上变了很多。在信息方面变了很多。
and so much disinformation out there. And, you know And it's really, and it's hard to communicate even today when you do accomplish some improbable things. And but he... Well, and I'll say that Mr. President, not to cut you off, but you have accomplished a lot of incredible things. And all three of you did in your presidencies,
而且有太多的虚假信息。而且，你知道，即使在今天，当你取得一些不可能的成就时，也很难沟通。而且他……嗯，总统先生，我不是要打断你，但你确实取得了很多不可思议的成就。你们三位在你们的总统任期内，
did amazing things. President Clinton, you did in your presidencies did amazing things president clinton you Left this country with a surplus which is the first time it had been done in a number of years President obama, you passed the affordable care act really started to tackle social issues President biden, you know, you look at the job your jobs numbers you look at The way you're battling inflation, which is not been easy. And you've done it with a lot of headwind and you've had a lot of people, a lot of voices and a lot. And we live in a time where there are a lot of voices.
都做了了不起的事情。克林顿总统，你在你的总统任期内做了了不起的事情，克林顿总统，你给这个国家留下了一笔盈余，这是多年来第一次做到这一点。奥巴马总统，你通过了《平价医疗法案》，真正开始解决社会问题。拜登总统，你知道，你看看你的就业数据，你看看你对抗通胀的方式，这并不容易。而且你是在有很多阻力的情况下做到的，你有很多声音，很多。我们生活在一个有很多声音的时代。
And my question is, considering the amazing work that all three of you have done, and especially the way you're doing right now, President Biden, it's so difficult, the messaging is getting is so tough to get the message out there because there is so much noise. What can you do? Just keep talking about it. You just keep, you have to connect with people as to how they're being affected, why it's happening.
我的问题是，考虑到你们三位所做的了不起的工作，特别是你们现在所做的方式，拜登总统，这太难了，信息传递变得非常困难，因为噪音太多了。你们能做什么？继续谈论它。你只需要继续，你必须与人们建立联系，让他们了解他们是如何受到影响的，为什么会发生这种情况。
And you know, one of the things that really startles me is I'm optimistic. I'm genuinely optimistic. And starting to break through. There's so much we have an opportunity to get done in ways that these guys set up and we're now gonna be able to close down. But for example, when we got elected, we were told we couldn't get anything done.
而且你知道，真正让我吃惊的一件事是，我很乐观。我真的很乐观。而且开始取得突破。我们有机会以这些家伙设定的方式完成很多事情，我们现在将能够结束它们。但例如，当我们当选时，我们被告知我们什么也做不成。
We couldn't get anything passed. Well, we got a little thing called a billion, $300 million to rebuild our roads, highways, internet. We got the chips and I've traveled around the world and said, why don't you come and invest in the United States of America? We got $650 billion invested offline. And on the Chips Act, we got about $56, $70 billion. And they're employing people.
我们什么也通过不了。嗯，我们得到了一笔叫做13亿美元的资金来重建我们的道路、高速公路、互联网。我们得到了芯片，我走遍了世界，说，为什么你们不来投资美利坚合众国？我们有6.5亿美元的离线投资。在《芯片法案》上，我们得到了大约560亿、700亿美元。而且他们正在雇佣员工。
And it just start, it takes takes wealth to kick in though. But are they, it seems like they're only watching certain things, reading certain things. Everybody's so siloed in the way in which they receive information. Could it be as simple as you, and you've got very smart people to suggest what it is that you do, but could it be as simple as just granting an hour to Sean Hannity and sit down and go, you tell me why the people who follow you think I'm not a good president. And just answer his questions. Call his bluff.
这只是开始，虽然需要财富来注入。但他们，看起来他们只看某些东西，读某些东西。每个人在接收信息的方式上都如此孤立。能不能简单点，你，你有非常聪明的人来建议你做什么，但能不能简单到给肖恩·汉尼提一个小时，坐下来，说，你告诉我为什么追随你的人认为我不是一个好总统。然后回答他的问题。揭穿他的虚张声势。
I mean, because the information, the facts are all there. It's particularly for that group of people, what you do is so much better suited than what the other agenda is talking about. So is it just a matter of just getting on that network? I don't get it. First of all, you guys are exactly right. Joe's got an unbelievable record of accomplishments. If you had told me that the unemployment rate after COVID was gonna be back down to 4% or lower. Yeah, lowest in 50 years, isn't it?
我的意思是，因为信息，事实都在那里。特别是对于那群人来说，你所做的比另一个议程所谈论的要合适得多。所以这只是去那个网络的问题吗？我不明白。首先，你们说得完全正确。乔有着令人难以置信的成就记录。如果你告诉我新冠后的失业率会回到4%或更低。是的，50年来最低，不是吗？
Absolutely, and if you had told me that 15 million jobs would have been created, that wages are higher now than they were pre-pandemic. Yeah, and the most jobs created in history, correct? In this four year period, yes. have been created, that wages are higher now than they were pre-pandemic. And the most jobs created in history, correct? In this four-year period, yes. In this four-year period, you've got African-American unemployment, right, which is always higher than the general population, the lowest it's been since record-keeping on the issue was
绝对是，如果你告诉我将创造1500万个就业岗位，现在的工资比大流行前还要高。是的，而且是历史上创造就业岗位最多的，对吧？在这四年期间，是的。创造了，现在的工资比大流行前还要高。而且是历史上创造就业岗位最多的，对吧？在这四年期间，是的。在这四年期间，你有非裔美国人的失业率，对吧，这总是高于一般人口，这是自该问题有记录以来最低的。
taken. So Joe's got a strong message to tell. Jason, you're right. The media environment's changed. During Bill's presidency, during my presidency, you already had Fox and Rush Limbaugh and so forth, but it was still going through basic broadcast TV, and the average person was still kind of getting a mix. Some
被采取。所以乔有一个强有力的信息要传达。杰森，你是对的。媒体环境变了。在比尔的总统任期内，在我的总统任期内，你已经有了福克斯和拉什·林博等等，但它仍然通过基本的广播电视进行，普通人仍然得到一种混合。一些
dissenting views. Part of what happened is that whole ecosystem moved on to social media and once it's on social media and it's on an algorithm and everybody's just getting their news selected essentially to suit their biases, penetrating that is real tough. It is very hard. But what do you say to the people who say on the other side the same thing? Well, you know, I would argue that actually
不同的观点。发生的一部分事情是整个生态系统转移到了社交媒体上，一旦它在社交媒体上，它就在算法上，每个人都只是得到他们选择的新闻，本质上是为了迎合他们的偏见，渗透这一点真的很难。这非常困难。但你对另一边说同样话的人怎么说？嗯，你知道，我会争辩说实际上
they've got some legitimate points in the sense that, you know, there's a side that doesn't recognize conservative thought or isn't respectful to some traditional values that they care about and so forth. The difference though is, and Jason touched on it, there's a difference between facts and opinions. And the one thing that our side
他们有一些合理的观点，因为，你知道，有一方不承认保守思想，或者不尊重他们关心的一些传统价值观等等。但区别在于，杰森提到了这一点，事实和观点之间是有区别的。而我们这一方的一件事
still pretty much sticks to is the facts. You may not agree with whatever's in the New York Times or whatever's on MSNBC, but generally they're not going to just make stuff up. And look, I was in office in 2016, and I would have loved to pretend that the election outcome wasn't what it was. That was painful. But we said, well, here are the facts, and there's a system of government that transcends
仍然相当坚持事实。你可能不同意《纽约时报》或MSNBC上的任何内容，但通常他们不会只是编造东西。看，我在2016年任职，我很想假装选举结果不是那样。那很痛苦。但我们说，好吧，这是事实，有一个政府体系超越了
that is more important than whoever wins this particular election. We're gonna abide by those facts and stick with democracy. And that is a shift that's taking place. Now, last point I'd make though, because Jason was asking, what do we do? I think Joe's point is right, and that is, you just keep on showing up and delivering the message
这比谁赢得这次特定选举更重要。我们将遵守这些事实并坚持民主。这是一个正在发生的转变。现在，我要说的最后一点，因为杰森在问，我们该怎么办？我认为乔的观点是对的，那就是，你只需要继续出现并传递信息
wherever you can, however you can, and if you talk to folks enough, all of us, Bill, Joe, myself, all have the experience of going to places where we may not be the most popular person. People may have some preconceived notions about Barack Hussein Obama. Mm-hmm.
无论你在哪里，无论你如何做，如果你和人们谈论得足够多，我们所有人，比尔，乔，我自己，都有去那些我们可能不是最受欢迎的地方的经历。人们可能对巴拉克·侯赛因·奥巴马有一些先入为主的观念。嗯哼。
Right? Jesus. Yeah. But if you show up and you make a human connection with people and you talk to them. Right. We'll be right back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So I just got back from the East Coast, where I'm fortunate
对吧？天哪。是的。但如果你出现并与人们建立人际联系，你和他们交谈。对。我们马上回来。这个节目由BetterHelp赞助。所以我刚从东海岸回来，在那里我很幸运
enough to have some very good friends that live there, but also good friends that live here on the West Coast as well. So, you know, talk about social battery, right? Your social battery can get drained so easily because you want to see all the people that you love and all the people that are important to you. But you do have to kind of schedule time for yourself.
能够有一些住在那里的非常好的朋友，但也有住在这里西海岸的好朋友。所以，你知道，谈谈社交电池，对吧？你的社交电池很容易耗尽，因为你想见你爱的所有人和对你重要的人。但你确实需要为自己安排时间。
So the balance of like the desire to see your friends and the guilt of not seeing them, but also needing your rest to reset yourself from the trip, right? It can be so easy to ignore our social battery and spread ourselves thin, especially with social gatherings picking up after the winter. What's the right amount of socializing for you
所以，想见朋友的愿望和没见他们的内疚感之间的平衡，但也需要休息来从旅行中重置自己，对吧？忽略我们的社交电池并让自己精疲力竭是很容易的，特别是在冬天过后社交聚会增加的情况下。对你来说，多少社交是合适的
and how do you recharge? Maybe you thrive around people or maybe you need some more alone time. Therapy can give you the self-awareness to build a social life that doesn't drain your battery. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch
以及你如何充电？也许你在人群中茁壮成长，或者也许你需要更多的独处时间。治疗可以给你自我意识，建立一个不会耗尽你电池的社交生活。如果你正在考虑开始治疗，试试BetterHelp。它完全在线，设计得方便、灵活，适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并切换
therapists anytime for no additional charge. Find your social sweet spot with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash Smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash Smartless. Smartless is brought to you in part by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover.
治疗师随时无需额外费用。用BetterHelp找到你的社交甜蜜点。今天访问BetterHelp.com/Smartless，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp，H-E-L-P点com斜杠Smartless。《Smartless》部分由Audible带给你。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有的音频娱乐。你总能找到你所爱的最好的东西或新的发现。
They offer an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, and tons more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases and next-to-listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. You know, I'm a huge Steve Martin fan, one of the reasons I got into the business. And I read his book years ago called Born Standing Up. And then when I saw it on Audible, I was like, oh my God, I have to hear Steve read it. And it's fantastic. And it's even
他们提供令人难以置信的有声读物选择，涵盖各种流派，从畅销书和新书到名人回忆录、悬疑和惊悚片、励志、健康、商业等等。Audible是你的惊险音频娱乐目的地，有备受期待的新书和为每种类型的惊悚片听众提供的下一本收听建议。作为Audible会员，你可以每月从整个目录中选择一个标题保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。你知道，我是史蒂夫·马丁的超级粉丝，我进入这个行业的原因之一。我几年前读过他的书，叫《站着出生》。然后当我在Audible上看到它时，我就想，天哪，我必须听史蒂夫读它。而且它太棒了。而且它甚至
better than reading it. You get to listen to the guy, one of your idols actually read his book that you love. It's such a good book and such a fantastic, clever title. Born Standing Up, I love that. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free
比读它更好。你听到了那个家伙，你的偶像之一，实际上读了他写的你喜欢的书。这是一本好书，标题如此精彩、聪明。《站着出生》，我喜欢那个。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless到500-500。那是audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless到500-500来免费试用Audible
for 30 days, audible.com slash smartless. We're brought to you in part by ZipRecruiter. So summer's coming up, that means a bunch of outdoor concerts, I'm gonna go to the Hollywood Bowl, I always go there. I go there a lot to go see John Williams every year. And it's really, really hard to get tickets, so I always try to get ahead of the game
30天，audible.com/smartless。我们部分由ZipRecruiter带给你。所以夏天快到了，这意味着很多户外音乐会，我要去好莱坞露天剧场，我总是去那里。我经常去那里看约翰·威廉姆斯，每年。而且很难买到票，所以我总是尽量走在前面
and order them really, really early so I can get good seats. Because I want the best, right? I want the best tickets possible. And when you want the best, you have to act quickly or someone else will get it instead. It's like if you're hiring for your business, you want to find the most talented people for your open rolls before the competition scoops them up. So what's the best way to do that? ZipRecruiter. ZipRecruiter finds qualified candidates fast. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless.
并很早很早地预订它们，这样我才能买到好座位。因为我想要最好的，对吧？我想要尽可能最好的票。当你想要最好的时候，你必须迅速行动，否则别人会抢走它。就像如果你在为你的企业招聘，你想要在竞争对手抢走他们之前为你的空缺职位找到最有才华的人。那么最好的方法是什么？ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter快速找到合格的候选人。现在你可以在ziprecruiter.com/smartless免费试用。
Got your eye on a rockstar candidate? ZipRecruiter's invite to apply feature lets you cut the line. Once you review ZipRecruiter's list of the most qualified candidates for your job, you can easily invite your top choices to apply to encourage them to apply sooner. Amp up your hiring performance with ZipRecruiter and find the best fast.
看中了一个摇滚明星候选人？ZipRecruiter的邀请申请功能让你插队。一旦你查看了ZipRecruiter为你职位提供的最合格候选人名单，你可以轻松邀请你的首选申请，鼓励他们更快申请。用ZipRecruiter提升你的招聘表现，快速找到最好的。
See why 4 out of 5 employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to try ZipRecruiter for free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. And back to the show. It makes your job harder, does it not? Or I'm asking you, when you wake up in the morning and you have people who say that they're opposed
看看为什么在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主中，有4/5在第一天内就得到了高质量的候选人。现在就去这个独家网址免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再说一遍，那是ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。回到节目。这让你的工作更难了，不是吗？或者我在问你，当你早上醒来，有人说他们反对
to what you do or what you believe or whatever, and yet you still have to govern and serve them no matter what. And it seems, right? And the other guy, he has no problem throwing anybody who's not with him under the bus. Look, when I got elected, I said I'm gonna be president for everyone.
你所做的或你所相信的或任何事情，但你仍然必须治理和服务他们，无论如何。而且似乎，对吧？而另一个人，他把任何不支持他的人扔到车轮下都没有问题。看，当我当选时，我说我要成为每个人的总统。
We have put more money into red states than blue states. Not a joke. Across the board, across the board, there's more money total invested in the red states and the blue states. Yes. Not a joke. Yeah, yeah. Across the board, across the board, there's more money total invested in the red states and the blue states, because then I'm gonna be president for everyone. Do they know that? Well, I think it's beginning, but whether it did or not,
我们投入到红州的钱比蓝州多。不是开玩笑。全面来看，全面来看，投入到红州的钱总额比蓝州多。是的。不是开玩笑。是的，是的。全面来看，全面来看，投入到红州的钱总额比蓝州多，因为我要成为每个人的总统。他们知道吗？嗯，我想这正在开始，但无论是否，
I have an obligation, it seems to me, to take care of the country. That's the job. But it's beginning to sink in a little bit. And you know, you have, like for example, did you ever think you'd see, these guys are great speakers, they're great presidents. Did you ever think you'd see a state of the union like the two I've had?
我有义务，在我看来，照顾这个国家。这就是工作。但这开始有点深入人心了。而且你知道，你有，例如，你有没有想过你会看到，这些家伙是伟大的演讲者，他们是伟大的总统。你有没有想过你会看到像我经历过的两次那样的国情咨文？
No, no. Yeah. Frankly, a little shameful. As the newest American here. Yeah. Because I'm Canadian, Rich. Yeah, I remember that. Yeah.
不，不。是的。坦率地说，有点可耻。作为这里最新的美国人。是的。因为我是加拿大人，里奇。是的，我记得那个。是的。
You know, Canadian, well, as the newest American here, because I'm Canadian originally. Yeah, I remember that. Why are you so proud of me? Well, I got a Canadian brother-in-law. Canadians are interesting, because they sneak up on you. You remember that movie, Invasion of the Body Snatchers? Yeah. Like they look like us, but you don't really know. Wayne, I saw you at the Raptors game back in the day. Actually, I love me some Canadians.
你知道，加拿大人，嗯，作为这里最新的美国人，因为我最初是加拿大人。是的，我记得那个。你为什么为我感到骄傲？嗯，我有一个加拿大姐夫。加拿大人很有趣，因为他们会悄悄地靠近你。你记得那部电影《人体入侵者》吗？是的。就像他们看起来像我们，但你真的不知道。韦恩，我以前在猛龙队的比赛中见过你。实际上，我喜欢加拿大人。
I'm always looking behind me when Will and I are walking, just like the third and then the Canadian. Is there, there is, and I don't mean to sound cynical with this, but there is a bit of a show element that the other guy seems to really relish in. He loves being and saying things that really attract some views, some clicks, like, you know, he's a fun show to watch, I'm sure.
当威尔和我走路时，我总是向后看，就像第三个，然后是加拿大人。有没有，确实有，我不是想听起来愤世嫉俗，但确实有一点表演元素，另一个人似乎真的很喜欢。他喜欢成为并说一些真正吸引一些观点、一些点击的事情，就像，你知道，他是一个有趣的节目，我相信。
Like the nicknames. Now, I know you three are uniquely qualified in keeping things classy and elevated and keeping respect around the office and the job, et cetera, but is there ever a thought of how one might be able to tack slightly towards the show to sort of combat that a little bit? And you're starting to do it
就像绰号。现在，我知道你们三位在保持优雅和提升，保持办公室和工作的尊重等方面具有独特的资格，等等，但有没有想过一个人如何能够稍微向节目靠拢，以某种方式对抗这一点？而且你开始这样做了
just a little bit, President Biden, and I think it's really like people are loving it, you're sort of giving it to them a little bit. Now, I know that's not, you know, some sort of contrived calculation you're making, but is there... It's a response. Yeah, exactly.
只是一点点，拜登总统，我认为这真的就像人们喜欢它，你有点给他们一点点。现在，我知道那不是，你知道，你正在做的某种人为计算，但有没有……这是一种回应。是的，没错。
But is there any thought to like... It's working though. It's time to kind of pull the gloves off a little bit and if they want a show, we'll give it to them. Well, I'm not so sure about the show, but I think if they want the truth, we'll give it to them. Yeah, amen. And just go straight at them.
但有没有想过……但这确实有效。是时候脱掉手套了，如果他们想要一个节目，我们会给他们。嗯，我不确定节目，但我认为如果他们想要真相，我们会给他们。是的，阿门。直接冲着他们去。
Look, you know, like I said, at the gridiron dinner, you know, we'll give it to them. Yeah, amen. And just go straight at them. Look, you know, like I said at the gridiron dinner, you know, this guy came up to me, asked me if we could borrow some money. That's a great lie. And I told him, Donald, I can't help you. All kids decide we can make jokes about it. But the end result is, look, we all know every major world leader. And I think one of the reasons Barack asked me to be vice president, I had some foreign
看，你知道，就像我说的，在格里迪隆晚宴上，你知道，我们会给他们。是的，阿门。直接冲着他们去。看，你知道，就像我在格里迪隆晚宴上说的，你知道，这家伙走到我面前，问我能不能借点钱。那是个伟大的谎言。我告诉他，唐纳德，我帮不了你。所有的孩子都决定我们可以拿它开玩笑。但最终的结果是，看，我们都知道每一位主要的世界领导人。而且我认为巴拉克请我做副总统的原因之一，我有一些外交方面的。
policy experience. And I've known these folks for a long time. I go to all these conferences that we all know. And Bill just came back from one on his own. Great help to us in Caribbean. And you know, almost every single time, not a joke, guys, whether it's the G7, the G20, all these heads of state, they'll wait till they can get me alone and grab my arm and say, you've got to win. Because quote, my democracy is a state, their democracy.
政策经验。我认识这些人很久了。我参加过我们大家都知道的所有会议。比尔刚独自参加完一个会议。他在加勒比地区帮了我们大忙。你们知道，几乎每一次，这不是开玩笑，伙计们，无论是七国集团（G7）、二十国集团（G20），还是所有这些国家元首，他们都会等到能单独见到我时，抓住我的胳膊说，你一定要赢。因为引用他们的话说，我的民主就是他们的民主。
Let me, since I'm not directly involved, I'll give you an example that I just had. Not very long ago, I went to Prague, Czechoslovakia, to celebrate the anniversary of the decision to expand NATO and include the Czech Republic and Hungary and Poland. And they know what it's like to live without democracy. They know what it's like not to be free. They know what it's like not to be free. They are adamantly in favor of President Biden's support for Ukraine. And they think we did the right thing to expand NATO.
既然我没有直接参与，我就举一个我刚经历的例子。不久前，我去了捷克共和国的布拉格，庆祝北约扩大并纳入捷克、匈牙利和波兰的决定。他们知道没有民主的生活是什么样的。他们知道没有自由是什么样的。他们知道没有自由是什么样的。他们坚决支持拜登总统对乌克兰的支持。他们认为我们扩大北约的决定是正确的。
And they know it's Russia's fault, not ours, what's happened in Ukraine. So it was amazing. All of them came to me and said, please tell me you're not gonna put us through all this again. what's happened in Ukraine. So it was amazing. All of them came to me and said, please tell me you're not going to put us through all this again. Yeah. Yeah.
他们知道乌克兰发生的事情是俄罗斯的错，而不是我们的错。所以这太棒了。他们所有人都来找我，说，请告诉我你不会让我们再经历这一切了。乌克兰发生的事情。所以这太棒了。他们所有人都来找我，说，请告诉我你不会让我们再经历这一切了。是的。是的。
Please tell me America's not going to run away from the world again. We need you. And in Poland, which is a very conservative country, culturally, religiously, they just voted overwhelmingly to throw out the old party because they thought they were too close to the Russians and put in the government that you dealt with when Hillary was Secretary of State because they support a free Ukraine. And I just showed up, man. I didn't go there to do a, they like me because I was with them in the beginning, but they
请告诉我美国不会再次背弃世界。我们需要你们。在波兰，这是一个在文化和宗教上非常保守的国家，他们刚刚以压倒性多数投票赶走了旧政党，因为他们认为旧政党与俄罗斯人走得太近，并选出了希拉里担任国务卿时你们打过交道的政府，因为他们支持一个自由的乌克兰。我只是露了个面，伙计。我不是去那里做……他们喜欢我，因为我从一开始就和他们在一起，但他们
are worried about tomorrow. I think Bill's point and Joe's point's important. You know, look, we all know America's not always lived up to its ideals. We got our warts, we got issues. But we do set the tone around the world. And part of what happened before Joe got elected during that four year period,
担心明天。我认为比尔和乔的观点很重要。你知道，看，我们都知道美国并不总是能达到其理想。我们有缺点，我们有问题。但我们确实在世界各地定下了基调。乔当选之前那四年里发生的部分事情是，
folks around the world started feeling as if the ideals of human rights freedom democracy that nobody was looking after that nobody was promoting that nobody was minding it and People like Putin became emboldened and you saw the Chinese and and even countries that were democracy start backsliding because they do still look to America as an example of what they hope a multiracial, multiethnic, multireligious big country can look like,
世界各地的人们开始觉得，人权、自由、民主的理想似乎没人管了，没人推动了，没人关心了。像普京这样的人变得胆大妄为，你看到中国，甚至一些民主国家也开始倒退，因为他们仍然把美国视为他们所希望的一个多种族、多民族、多宗教的大国应该有的样子，
that maybe people can still get along and act decently towards each other even if they don't all look the same and don't all talk the same and all come from the same place. That's what makes America exceptional. And if you start getting into a situation in which we don't believe our own declaration of independence, if we're not acting on behalf of the things that we say we stand for,
也许人们仍然可以和睦相处，即使他们长得不一样，说的不一样，来自不同的地方，也能体面地对待彼此。这就是美国卓越的地方。如果你开始陷入一种我们不再相信自己的《独立宣言》的境地，如果我们不再为我们所声称捍卫的事物而行动，
that has ripple effects all around the globe. And these guys are exactly right. I just came back from Europe, and every meeting I had, the only thing people were concerned about was what's gonna happen in this next election because they understand what the stakes are. I'm sorry, just on that point President Obama, were you were you surprised during those five years of the last administration how quickly that protection and passion for democracy was diluted? How prime
那会在全球产生连锁反应。这些人说得完全正确。我刚从欧洲回来，我参加的每一次会议，人们唯一关心的问题就是下次选举会发生什么，因为他们明白利害攸关。抱歉，奥巴马总统，关于这一点，在上一届政府的五年里，您是否惊讶于对民主的保护和热情消退得如此之快？这个国家
the country was to just sort of dissolve and and get lazy with it and let it go. You know, I will say, and Bill saw this begin to happen during his presidency, it then accelerated during my presidency, I have been surprised that there haven't been guardrails inside the Republican party. Trump didn't surprise me. No.
是多么容易就解体、变得懒散并任其发展。你知道，我会说，比尔在他总统任期内开始看到这种情况发生，在我总统任期内这种情况加速了，我感到惊讶的是，共和党内部竟然没有护栏。特朗普并没有让我感到惊讶。不。
I mean, I like- He was the natural conclusion to me. Is that why? No, I mean, you watch Trump's campaign, you watch his career. Yeah, he's never changed. If you know anybody who's- He's a huckster.
我的意思是，我喜欢——对我来说，他是自然而然的结果。是因为这个吗？不，我的意思是，你观察特朗普的竞选，你观察他的职业生涯。是的，他从未改变。如果你认识任何……他是个骗子。
I mean, he comes from New York. There's nobody in New York who does business with him. No, he has no money. Lend him money. No. He's not considered a serious guy here, but. So I wasn't, I was surprised he was elected, but I wasn't surprised in terms of his behavior. I did expect, and I suspect Bill and Joe,
我的意思是，他来自纽约。在纽约没人跟他做生意。不，他没钱。借钱给他。不。他在这里不被认为是一个严肃的人，但是。所以我并不惊讶他当选了，但我对他的行为并不感到惊讶。我确实预料到，而且我怀疑比尔和乔，
you'd agree with this, that there would be some folks in the Republican Party who would say, no, you can't go that far. You can't start praising Putin and saying that his intelligence is better than the US intelligence agencies. Were you surprised that there were 60-some million people that bought it and voted for him and then did it again? Well, I think that we can't discount
你们会同意这一点，共和党内会有一些人说，不，你不能走那么远。你不能开始赞美普京，说他的情报比美国情报机构更好。你们是否惊讶于有六千多万人买账并投票给他，然后又投了一次？嗯，我认为我们不能忽视
the fact that the world's changing quick. And when the world changes quick, people get scared and they get confused and we had a historic recession in 2008, 2009 where the financial system almost collapses. We end up having, we'd obviously already gone through 9-11. You got globalization, you have suddenly people feeling as if they're losing manufacturing jobs. Some of the towns that, in Illinois,
世界正在迅速变化这一事实。当世界变化太快时，人们会感到害怕和困惑。我们在2008年、2009年经历了历史性的衰退，金融体系几乎崩溃。我们最终经历了，我们显然已经经历了9/11事件。你有全球化，你突然发现人们觉得他们正在失去制造业工作。在伊利诺伊州的一些城镇，
where I was representing, Arkansas, where Bill was working, you see people starting to feel like they're losing status. Suddenly, you've got the internet and social media and people are being flooded with all kinds of stuff and they don't know how to sort it all out. And when people get scared and concerned, then the appeal of somebody who says, I'm going to make it like it used to be
我曾代表那里，阿肯色州，比尔曾在那工作，你看到人们开始觉得他们正在失去地位。突然间，你有了互联网和社交媒体，人们被各种各样的东西淹没了，他们不知道如何理清这一切。当人们感到害怕和担忧时，那么一个说“我要让一切回到过去”的人的吸引力，
where you don't have to worry about it. And, you know, men are men and women know their place. the appeal of somebody who says, I'm gonna make it like it used to be where you don't have to worry about it. Men are men and women know their place and that message can sometimes have some appeal. Look, again, I love this country. I am so... You better. I'm Canadian. It is the best country in the world.
在那里你不需要担心这些。而且，你知道，男人就是男人，女人知道她们的位置。一个说“我要让一切回到过去，让你不必担心”的人的吸引力，男人就是男人，女人知道她们的位置，这种信息有时会有一些吸引力。看，再说一次，我爱这个国家。我非常……你最好爱它。我是加拿大人。它是世界上最好的国家。
You've only been to two countries. But... But it's... He watches CNN International though. It's true. I've been to Canada and the US. No, I agree with that. And by the way, it's a phenomenal country.
你只去过两个国家。但是……但是它……不过他看CNN国际频道。这是真的。我去过加拿大和美国。不，我同意这一点。顺便说一句，这是一个了不起的国家。
When it's at its best, it is the best. The rest of the world looks to us. Absolutely. No matter what you say, no matter how you characterize it, there's not a single country in the world that does not think we're the single most consequential country in the world. Not a single one. Including our enemies. Including our enemies. I mean, across the board. Especially.
当它处于最佳状态时，它是最好的。世界其他地方仰望着我们。绝对是。无论你怎么说，无论你怎么描述它，世界上没有一个国家不认为我们是世界上最重要的国家。一个都没有。包括我们的敌人。包括我们的敌人。我的意思是，全面来看。尤其是。
If there's a problem around the world, you know, if there's a natural disaster, if there is a crisis, nobody's calling Moscow or Beijing expecting them to help. Right. Everybody's looking to Washington. But beyond that, here's the deal. Look, think about it. When Trump got elected, he said he's gonna go America first, America alone. He, look at who he talks about his best friends being,
如果世界上出现问题，你知道，如果发生自然灾害，如果发生危机，没人会打电话给莫斯科或北京指望他们帮忙。对吧。每个人都在看着华盛顿。但除此之外，重点是。看，想一想。当特朗普当选时，他说他要搞“美国优先”，美国孤立。他，看看他谈论他最好的朋友是谁，
Kim Jong-un, North Korea, and I'm serious. Jack Nicklaus. Hey listen, he won two golf championships last week. The regular championship and the senior. I told him when he won, I told him he came into the upstairs oval and we bumped into each other and said something about playing golf. I said, look, I'll give you two strokes if you carry
金正恩，朝鲜，我是认真的。杰克·尼克劳斯。嘿，听着，他上周赢了两场高尔夫锦标赛。常规锦标赛和高级锦标赛。当他赢的时候我告诉他，我告诉他他走进楼上的椭圆形办公室，我们碰到了，说了些关于打高尔夫的事。我说，看，如果你自己背球包，
your own bag. Hey, do you know this? President Biden, do you know that Kim Jong-un, he had 18 holes in one once? Yeah. So we're not far off that with this guy. I'm looking forward to your guys' merch coming out. I've seen holes in one once. Yeah, so we're not far off that with this guy. I'm looking forward to your guys' merch coming out.
我就让你两杆。嘿，你知道这个吗？拜登总统，你知道金正恩曾经打出过18个一杆进洞吗？是的。所以我们离这家伙不远了。我很期待你们的周边产品出来。我见过一杆进洞。是的，所以我们离这家伙不远了。我很期待你们的周边产品出来。
Go ahead. Do you guys have an apparatus, a mechanism whereby you can contact one another like this without anybody connecting to that? Like a bat phone? It's called a smartphone. Do you have one of these? What I mean, can you do that? Great.
继续。你们有没有一种装置、一种机制，可以像这样联系彼此，而不需要任何人连接？像蝙蝠侠电话那样？这叫智能手机。你们有这个吗？我的意思是，你们能那样做吗？太棒了。
Do you guys text each other? Yeah, I mean like emojis. I don't text much, but we pick up the phone and talk to each other. I love that. With no one else listening and no one else connecting the call. We can't be sure of that. We're not positive of the cyber side. But does President Obama, like he picks up and he goes, hang on, I add president Clinton Yeah, I'm gonna merge calls. That's a little too advanced, right? You might need a 25 year old aid to help on the merger thing. It all I love somebody else
你们会互发短信吗？是的，我的意思是像表情符号。我不怎么发短信，但我们会拿起电话互相交谈。我喜欢这样。没有别人在听，也没有别人在接通电话。我们不能确定这一点。我们对网络安全方面没有把握。但奥巴马总统，他拿起电话说，等一下，我加上克林顿总统，是的，我要合并通话。那有点太先进了，对吧？你可能需要一个25岁的助手来帮忙处理合并的事情。我喜欢别人
I mean one plus one plus one makes ten with you guys So I just I want to know like do you all miss something specific about the holding office? Obviously except for you because you're in office, do you guys miss something I miss not having office yeah yeah yeah look look everybody talks about Air Force one yeah sure marine one yeah it's pretty convenient I won't lie but I'll tell you the thing I miss the most is you remember those music concerts I used to do at, you can basically invite anybody. Yeah.
我的意思是，你们在一起就是一加一加一等于十。所以我只是想知道，你们是否都怀念担任公职的某些具体方面？显然除了你，因为你还在任，你们怀念什么吗？我怀念没有办公室，是的，是的，看，看，每个人都谈论空军一号，是的，当然，海军陆战队一号，是的，这很方便，我不会撒谎，但我会告诉你我最怀念的是，你还记得我过去举办的那些音乐会吗？你可以邀请任何人。是的。
Yeah. And you have this concert. And I mean, we got Stevie Wonder. Yeah, yeah. Paul McCartney. Everybody will show up. They'll show up. I'll bet they'll still take you home.
是的。你举办这场音乐会。我的意思是，我们请到了史蒂夫·汪达。是的，是的。保罗·麦卡特尼。每个人都会出现。他们会出现。我敢打赌他们仍然会带你回家。
And they've got, they do these rehearsals the night before a lot of times, and you can kind of sneak down, and you can just sit there and watch. You know, Mick Jagger practicing with B.B. King or something on a blues night. I do miss that. That's so good.
他们经常在前一天晚上进行排练，你可以溜下去，坐在那里观看。你知道，米克·贾格尔在蓝调之夜和B.B.金一起练习之类的。我确实怀念那个。那太棒了。
I miss the fact they don't play a song when you walk in a room anymore. Sure. Oh, we should have done that today. I was lost for three weeks after I left office. But let me tell you something serious. This is one reason that I so badly want President Biden to be reelected. What I really miss is the job.
我怀念当你走进房间时他们不再播放音乐的事实。当然。哦，我们今天应该那样做的。我离开办公室后迷茫了三周。但让我告诉你一些严肃的事情。这就是我如此渴望拜登总统连任的一个原因。我真正怀念的是这份工作。
Not doing it. I'm glad. I believe in the two-term limit strongly. Yeah But what I learned was on the worst day When nothing was going right and problems are everywhere there were still something you could do They would make somebody's life better. I love there is no job like that on earth I love that and I want somebody who appreciates that I trust And I want somebody who appreciates that I trust To make the most of that every day. Yeah, because they'll be bad days No matter who gets elected, but he'll get up and he'll start thinking about that
不是做它。我很高兴。我强烈支持两届任期限制。是的，但我学到的是，在最糟糕的一天，当一切都不顺利，到处都是问题时，仍然有一些事情你可以做，能让某人的生活变得更好。我喜欢，地球上没有这样的工作。我喜欢这一点，我想要一个我信任的人来欣赏这一点，
And I think his opponent will be thinking about himself Who I can who I can get even with you know who I can send away who I can get even with, you know, who I can send away, who I can manage. His judgment is... Joe Biden will make the best of the bad days. And the team that you have assembled and your comfort with deferment, you know, you're... I don't know, for me personally, I just, I love leaders that have the confidence to hire those that they respect, that might make them a little nervous. And also not to think that you're the, that every idea you're gonna have every,
并每天充分利用它。是的，因为无论谁当选，都会有糟糕的日子，但他会起床，开始思考那个。我认为他的对手会只想着他自己，我可以报复谁，我可以把谁送走，我可以报复谁，我可以把谁送走，我可以管理谁。他的判断力是……乔·拜登会把糟糕的日子过得最好。你组建的团队，以及你对授权的舒适感，你知道，你……我不知道，对我个人来说，我只是，我喜欢那些有信心聘用他们所尊重的人的领导者，即使这可能会让他们感到一点紧张。而且也不要认为你是……你不会有每一个想法，每一个……
you know, we've had people like, we had leaders like that in the middle part of the last century, who were put into government by presidents of old, and they made a lot of decisions that they thought that they were right about, and they were terrible people. And when you let somebody, when that happens, when you think that you've got all the answers,
你知道，我们上个世纪中叶有那样的领导者，他们被老总统们安排进政府，他们做出了很多他们认为正确但实际上很糟糕的决定。当你让某人，当这种情况发生时，当你认为你拥有所有答案时，
is the moment you don't. I think. Like Ron Klain, bringing us out of COVID, like it's just, and on and on and on, the way in which that you've surrounded yourself with the absolute best this country has to offer. I made a commitment. I have an administration that looks like America.
就是你不再拥有答案的时刻。我想。就像罗恩·克莱恩，带我们走出新冠疫情，就像这样，等等等等，你以这种方式让自己被这个国家所能提供的绝对最好的人才所包围。我做出了承诺。我的政府看起来像美国。
I have more women in my cabinet. I have more, I've appointed more black circuit court judges than every other president combined in American history. I've kept my commitment about putting a black woman on the Supreme Court. I've had an opportunity to go out and get the best people. And by the way, I sometimes pick the phone and ask these guys who they think are the best people and by the way I sometimes pick the phone and ask these guys who they think are the best people and I'm looking for people that that most of all though not just are good
我的内阁里有更多的女性。我任命的黑人巡回法院法官比美国历史上其他所有总统加起来还要多。我信守了让黑人女性进入最高法院的承诺。我有机会出去寻找最好的人才。顺便说一句，我有时会拿起电话问这些人他们认为谁是最好的人才，顺便说一句，我有时会拿起电话问这些人他们认为谁是最好的人才，我寻找的人不仅是优秀的，
But care about what they're doing whereas the other guy is only hiring people that won't talk back You know and that's like I talk back. Yeah What are those things that you look back on because the other guy is? As we know, no capacity for this, and President Obama, I'll start with you, what are the things that you think about that keep you, are there things that you look back and you go,
而且关心他们正在做的事情，而另一个人只雇佣那些不会顶嘴的人。你知道，就像我顶嘴一样。是的，你回顾过去时会想到哪些事情？因为另一个人是？我们知道，没有这种能力，奥巴马总统，我先从您开始，您回顾过去时会想到哪些事情，让您……有没有什么事情您回顾过去时会说，
geez, I wish that had worked out a little bit better? Not necessarily regrets, but things that you would wish had- Handing off the baton in 2016, definitely. But I think Bill's point is the right one, which is when you're sitting in that office, you are essentially a relay runner. You've taken a bunch of problems
天哪，我希望那件事能做得更好一点？不一定是遗憾，但您希望……2016年交接接力棒，绝对是。但我认为比尔的观点是正确的，那就是当你坐在那个办公室里时，你本质上是一个接力赛跑者。你从前任总统那里接手了一堆问题，
from the previous president, and you're working through them as best you can, you're running the best race you can, and then you hand it off. During that time where you've got the baton in your hand and you're running, if you are focused on every day, can I make things a little bit better? Because you're not gonna make them perfect.
你尽你所能解决它们，你尽你所能跑好这场比赛，然后你把它交接出去。在你手里拿着接力棒奔跑的那段时间里，如果你专注于每一天，我能让事情变得更好一点吗？因为你不可能让它们变得完美。
There are too many problems, they're too hard. If you make them a little better, then a lot of people are helped. So the Affordable Care Act wasn't perfect. We didn't get everybody health insurance. But we got- It was a big deal. Tens of millions of people.
问题太多了，它们太难了。如果你能让它们变得更好一点，那么很多人就会得到帮助。所以《平价医疗法案》并不完美。我们没有让每个人都获得医疗保险。但我们做到了……这是一件大事。数千万人。
Really big deal. We got tens of millions of people. You can say the real quote on the show. It was a big fucking deal. We got tens of millions of people health insurance. And my successor tried to kill it. Didn't succeed because it was starting to actually work. You get it passed on to Joe, and what does he do?
真的是件大事。我们让数千万人。你可以在节目中引用那句名言。那是一件该死的大事。我们让数千万人获得了医疗保险。而我的继任者试图废除它。没有成功，因为它实际上开始起作用了。你把它传给乔，他做了什么？
He then takes what's already in place and builds on it. Expands the subsidies so that more people can start getting on it. Expands Medicaid so that more people can get on it. And so with all the changes he made, you know, healthcare in America is still not perfect. There's still folks who are having a tough time. But what has happened is that even more people
他然后利用已经到位的措施并在此基础上进行建设。扩大补贴，让更多人能加入。扩大医疗补助，让更多人能加入。所以，尽管他做了所有这些改变，你知道，美国的医疗保健仍然不完美。仍然有人过得很艰难。但发生的事情是，更多的人
have gotten coverage, and now Joe caps insulin at 35 bucks, which means that people who've got diabetes and really desperately need help, they're not getting price gouged. And he's negotiating with Big Pharma to make sure that drug prices are affordable the way they are in Canada. And so what you get are these incremental steps.
获得了保险，现在乔将胰岛素价格上限设定为35美元，这意味着那些患有糖尿病且非常迫切需要帮助的人，不会再被价格欺诈。他正在与大型制药公司谈判，以确保药品价格像在加拿大那样负担得起。所以你得到的是这些渐进的步骤。
You're never satisfied, to answer your question, Will, you're never satisfied when you leave, because there's always gonna be a bunch of stuff that's undone. But I couldn't have done the Affordable Care Act if Bill hadn't made the efforts he did around the Children's Health Insurance Program. And Joe then builds on us.
你永远不会满足，回答你的问题，威尔，当你离开时你永远不会满足，因为总有一堆事情没做完。但如果比尔没有在儿童健康保险计划方面做出努力，我就不可能完成《平价医疗法案》。而乔随后在我们基础上进行了建设。
And that's what you're hoping for each and every time. And let me say this, last point I'll make. It's not always just Democrats. George Bush and I had a huge number of differences. But he set up this program called PEPFAR that provided drugs and support and help for people in Sub-Saharan Africa and around the world who had HIV
这就是你每次所希望的。让我说这一点，我最后要说的一点。这并不总是只有民主党人。乔治·布什和我有很多分歧。但他设立了一个名为PEPFAR的项目，为撒哈拉以南非洲和世界各地患有艾滋病毒的人提供药物、支持和帮助，
in the midst of the HIV AIDS epidemic. And because of his program, millions of lives, tens of millions of lives were saved. And we then built on that program. So it doesn't just have to be a partisan thing. Part of what you want though is somebody with Joe's decency and basic focus on the American people and who have a sense of responsibility to say,
在艾滋病流行期间。因为他的项目，数百万人的生命，数千万人的生命得到了拯救。然后我们在这个项目的基础上进行了建设。所以它不一定非得是党派之争。你想要的是一个像乔那样具有体面和基本关注美国人民的人，并且有责任感说，
all right, I've inherited some stuff, some of it's good, some of it are problems, what more can I do? And that's the attitude Joe has. We'll be right back. We get support from State Farm. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. When you hear those words, you can feel good knowing that State Farm is there to help you
好吧，我继承了一些东西，有些是好的，有些是问题，我还能做什么？这就是乔的态度。我们马上回来。我们得到了State Farm的支持。像个好邻居，State Farm就在那里。当你听到这些话时，你会感到欣慰，因为你知道State Farm在那里帮助你
feel supported with the coverage you need for your car, your home, and even boats, motorcycles, RVs, and other things that matter to you. When things get complicated and you need ways to get help, State Farm gives you options there too. Maybe you like to handle things in person or on the phone with your local agent, or you prefer to do it on statefarm.com or on their award-winning app. State Farm lets you do things your way. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there.
感受到支持，为你提供汽车、房屋，甚至船只、摩托车、房车以及其他对你重要的事情所需的保险。当事情变得复杂，你需要寻求帮助的方法时，State Farm也为你提供了选择。也许你喜欢亲自或通过电话与当地代理人处理事情，或者你更喜欢在statefarm.com或他们的获奖应用程序上操作。State Farm让你以自己的方式处理事情。像个好邻居，State Farm就在那里。
I'm Afua Hirsch. I'm Peter Frankopan. And in our podcast, Legacy, we explore the lives of some of the biggest characters in history. This season, we delve into the life of Alan Turing. Why are we talking about Alan Turing, Peter? Alan Turing is the father of computer science and some of those questions we're thinking about today around artificial intelligence.
我是Afua Hirsch。我是Peter Frankopan。在我们的播客《遗产》（Legacy）中，我们探索历史上一些最伟大人物的生活。这一季，我们深入研究艾伦·图灵的生活。为什么我们要谈论艾伦·图灵，彼得？艾伦·图灵是计算机科学之父，也是我们今天正在思考的关于人工智能的一些问题的先驱。
Turing was so involved in setting and framing what some of those questions were, but he's also interesting for lots of other reasons, Afro. He had such a fascinating life. He was unapologetically gay at a time when that was completely criminalised and stigmatised. And from his imagination, he created ideas that have formed a very physical, practical foundation for all of the technology on which our lives depend. And on top of that, he's responsible for being part of a team that saved millions, maybe even tens of millions of lives because of his work during the Second World War using maths and computer science to code break. So join us on Legacy wherever you get your podcasts.
图灵在设定和构建其中一些问题方面参与度很高，但他因为许多其他原因也很有趣，Afro。他有着如此迷人的人生。在那个同性恋被完全定罪和污名化的时代，他毫不掩饰自己的同性恋身份。凭借他的想象力，他创造了构成了我们生活所依赖的所有技术的非常物理、实际的基础的想法。最重要的是，他是一个团队的一员，该团队拯救了数百万，甚至可能是数千万人的生命，因为他在第二次世界大战期间利用数学和计算机科学进行密码破译的工作。所以，无论你在哪里获取播客，都请加入我们的《遗产》。
I'm Alice Levine. And I'm Matt Ford. and we're the presenters of British Scandal. And in our latest series, Hitler's Angel, we tell the story of scandalous beauty Diana Mosley, British aristocrat, Mitford sister and fascist sympathiser. Like so many great British stories, it starts at a lavish garden party. Diana meets the dashing fascist Oswald Mosley. She's captivated by his politics but also by his very good looks. It's not a classic rom-com story but when she falls in love with Mosley she's on a collision course with her family, her friends and her whole country. There is some romance though. The couple tied the knot in a ceremony organised by
我是Alice Levine。我是Matt Ford。我们是《英国丑闻》（British Scandal）的主持人。在我们最新的系列节目《希特勒的天使》（Hitler's Angel）中，我们讲述了丑闻缠身的美女戴安娜·莫斯利的故事，她是英国贵族、米特福德姐妹之一，也是法西斯同情者。像许多伟大的英国故事一样，它始于一场奢华的花园派对。戴安娜遇到了风度翩翩的法西斯分子奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利。她不仅被他的政治主张所吸引，也被他英俊的外表所吸引。这不是一个经典的浪漫喜剧故事，但当她爱上莫斯利时，她就与她的家人、朋友和整个国家走上了冲突的道路。不过确实有一些浪漫。这对夫妇在一个由……组织的仪式上喜结连理
a great uncelebrated wedding planner, Adolf Hitler. So it's less Notting Hill, more Nuremberg. When Britain took on the Nazis, Diana had to choose between love or betrayal. This is the story of Diana Mosley on her journey from glamorous socialite to political prisoner. Listen to British Scandal on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, I'm Emily, one of the hosts of Terribly Famous, the show that takes you inside the lives of our biggest celebrities. Some of them hit the big time overnight, some have
一位伟大的、未被赞颂的婚礼策划师，阿道夫·希特勒。所以这与其说是《诺丁山》，不如说是《纽伦堡》。当英国对抗纳粹时，戴安娜必须在爱与背叛之间做出选择。这就是戴安娜·莫斯利从迷人的社交名媛到政治犯的旅程故事。在Wondery应用程序或任何你获取播客的地方收听《英国丑闻》。你好，我是Emily，《非常出名》（Terribly Famous）的主持人之一，这个节目带你走进我们最大名人的生活。他们中的一些人一夜成名，一些人
to plug away for years. But in our latest series, we're talking about a man who was world famous before he was even born. A life of extreme privilege that was mapped out from the start, but left him struggling to find his true purpose. A man who, compared to his big brother, felt a bit, you know, spare. Yes, it's Prince Harry. You might think you know everything about him, but trust me, there's even more. We follow Harry and the obsessive, all-consuming relationship of his life. Not with Meghan, but the British tabloid press. Hounded and harassed, Harry is taking on an institution
不得不努力多年。但在我们最新的系列节目中，我们谈论的是一个在出生前就闻名世界的人。一种从一开始就规划好的极端特权生活，却让他难以找到自己真正的人生目标。一个与他的哥哥相比，感觉有点，你知道，多余的人。是的，他是哈里王子。你可能认为你了解关于他的一切，但相信我，还有更多。我们跟随哈里和他生命中那种痴迷的、消耗一切的关系。不是与梅根，而是与英国小报媒体。受到骚扰和纠缠，哈里正在挑战一个机构
almost every bit as powerful as his own royal family. Follow Terribly Famous wherever you listen to podcasts, or listen early and ad-free on Wandery Plus on Apple Podcasts or the Wandery app. And now, back to the show. So then what are the issues coming up that people are focusing on that you believe are the wrong things or they may be the right things, and what should they be focusing on? I think they should be focusing on a couple things. And number one, we're going to, in the second term,
几乎和他的皇室家族一样强大。无论你在哪里收听播客，都请关注《非常出名》，或者在Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序上提前收听无广告版本。现在，回到节目。那么，人们正在关注的、你认为是不对的，或者可能是对的问题是什么？他们应该关注什么？我认为他们应该关注几件事。第一，在第二个任期内，
God willing, we're going to make sure that we do something about gun violence in this country. Yes. The idea that we allow assault weapons to be sold in magazines with 100 rounds, it's just bizarre. Well, President Biden, I'm so glad to hear you say that because that was going to be my other question,
上帝保佑，我们要确保在这个国家采取行动解决枪支暴力问题。是的。我们允许销售带有100发子弹弹匣的突击武器的想法，简直太离谱了。嗯，拜登总统，我很高兴听到你这么说，因为那是我要问的另一个问题，
which is the Democrats never said we want to take your guns away. Absolutely not. You never said that. No, by the way, we got to be smart about what's going on. You just don't need to kill a deer with an AR-15. The Second Amendment, which I, when I taught law school,
那就是民主党人从来没有说过我们想拿走你们的枪。绝对没有。你从来没说过。不，顺便说一句，我们必须对正在发生的事情保持聪明。你根本不需要用AR-15来猎鹿。第二修正案，当我教法学院时，
the Second Amendment wasn't absolute ever. You weren't able to have a cannon when you were, you know, the side of the, you know, the liberty is water with the blood of patriots. I mean, that's a bunch of crap. Well, it kind of brings us back to… Mr. President, we have a listener question that he already knows about, but if you want to read it to him, it's a listener call-in question. Uh-oh.
第二修正案从来都不是绝对的。当你……你知道，自由是用爱国者的鲜血浇灌的，那是一堆废话。嗯，这有点让我们回到了……总统先生，我们有一个听众问题，他已经知道了，但如果你想读给他听，这是一个听众打进来的问题。噢噢。
Okay. This is unusual, but I think I know who it's from. We have a caller here. Mr. President, I'm assuming he's talking about Mr. President Biden here. You have done so much for this country in the past three short years. You've been the architect of an incredible bipartisan infrastructure deal. Under your leadership, America has been running a white hot economy.
好的。这很不寻常，但我认为我知道它是谁问的。我们这里有一位来电者。总统先生，我假设他在这里指的是拜登总统。在过去短短三年里，您为这个国家做了这么多。您是令人难以置信的两党基础设施协议的建筑师。在您的领导下，美国一直保持着白热化的经济。
Inflation has been plummeting and unemployment remains in an all time historic low. But like so many Americans, I dread the possibility of having to listen to the grating voice of a narcissist man child on our airwaves for God knows how many more years. He's a bully that can barely manage his own personal, his personal own life, I have a feeling this is about me, has the strangest tan, no that's Will,
通货膨胀一直在暴跌，失业率保持在历史最低水平。但像许多美国人一样，我害怕不得不听一个自恋的巨婴在我们的广播中发出刺耳的声音，天知道还要听多少年。他是个几乎无法管理自己个人生活的恶霸，我有一种感觉这是在说我，他有最奇怪的晒黑，不，那是威尔，
and he takes golf way more seriously than any adult man should. So Mr. President, my question is, now that you're sitting directly across from Will Arnett, is there anything, is there nothing you or Congress can do to get him to shut his big fat mouth? I'll take my question, my answer off the air. That's Justin T. from New York City.
而且他对待高尔夫比任何成年男人都认真。所以总统先生，我的问题是，既然您现在正坐在威尔·阿奈特对面，难道您或国会就真的什么都做不了，让他闭上那张大嘴吗？我会下线回答我的问题。那是来自纽约市的贾斯汀·塞洛克斯。
Justin Theroux. Justin Theroux, sleeveless. We don't know if it's Theroux. Justin, there are certain powers. Justin Theroux. Justin Theroux, sleepless. We don't know if it's Theroux. Justin, there are certain powers that are beyond the presidency. And that's well beyond my presidential power. I asked you, President Biden, last time if you'd make me golf star, and you never answered me.
贾斯汀·塞洛克斯。贾斯汀·塞洛克斯，无袖。我们不知道是不是塞洛克斯。贾斯汀，有些权力是超越总统职权的。那完全超出了我的总统权力。拜登总统，上次我问您是否能让我成为高尔夫明星，您从来没回答我。
I had to call Trump, and he wasn't sure. I want to know, like, Well, I just wanted to say, we're kind of back where we started, which was the whole idea of the messaging and what's good for people. And we're all so hung up on, are you Democrat? Are you blue or red? Yeah, but that's what the campaigns are for.
我不得不打电话给特朗普，他不确定。我想知道，嗯，我只是想说，我们回到了我们开始的地方，也就是关于信息传递和什么对人们有益的整个想法。我们都太纠结于，你是民主党人吗？你是蓝色还是红色？是的，但这就是竞选的目的。
Look, the average voter wants to do the right thing. But how much bandwidth they have for politics? I mean, they've got to pay the right thing. But how much bandwidth they have for politics. I mean, they've got to pay the bills, they've got to take care of the kids' health care, they've got to make sure the school business is alright if you have children who are school age. I mean, there's just so many things they have to do. That's our job.
看，普通选民想做正确的事。但他们有多少精力用于政治？我的意思是，他们必须支付……但他们有多少精力用于政治。我的意思是，他们必须支付账单，他们必须照顾孩子的医疗保健，如果他们有学龄儿童，他们必须确保学校的事情没问题。我的意思是，他们必须做的事情太多了。那是我们的工作。
That's partly why we're here. That's why you're doing a public service by asking us questions and letting us... That's what why we're here. That's why you're doing a public service by asking us questions and letting us, that's what campaigns are for. It seems like- That's what you have to use them for. It seems like they're sort of making it sort of this binary choice between social issues
这就是我们在这里的部分原因。这就是为什么你通过问我们问题并让我们……这就是我们在这里的原因。这就是为什么你通过问我们问题并让我们……这就是竞选的目的。看起来……这就是你必须利用它们的目的。看起来他们似乎正在把这变成一种关于社会问题
or pocketbook issues. And if you're gonna go for the social issues, then you're gonna take a hit on the pocket. If you're gonna vote for pocketbook issues, you're going to take a hit on the pocket. If you're going to vote for pocketbook issues, you're going to lose all the social issues. Like I... But that's not... But here's the truth. The truth is, almost all the rational positions on social issues and on those issues that
或钱包问题的二元选择。如果你要选择社会问题，那么你在钱包上就会受到打击。如果你要投票支持钱包问题，你就会在钱包上受到打击。如果你要投票支持钱包问题，你就会失去所有的社会问题。就像我……但那不是……但事实是。事实是，几乎所有关于社会问题和那些问题上的理性立场，
are like unions, for example, they all, in fact, grow the economy if you do the right thing. They grow the economy if you do the right thing. They grow the economy. The economy grew under Bill, it grew under Joe, it grew under me. And the reason it grows is when everybody's got a stake, when everybody's making money. Morale. When people are getting paid decent wages, they have decent benefits, they feel better, they go shopping, they might even listen to this podcast.
比如工会，它们实际上，如果你做正确的事，都会促进经济增长。如果你做正确的事，它们会促进经济增长。它们促进经济增长。经济在比尔任内增长了，在乔任内增长了，在我任内增长了。它增长的原因是当每个人都有份时，当每个人都在赚钱时。士气。当人们得到体面的工资，他们有体面的福利，他们感觉更好，他们去购物，他们甚至可能听这个播客。
And so. They gotta be pretty bored. But the point is that American economic history shows whenever prosperity is broadly based, and all of us ran campaigns with this basic premise that if you give everybody a fair shot, everybody does better. So this whole idea that we gotta somehow make it
所以。他们一定很无聊。但重点是，美国经济史表明，每当繁荣广泛分布时，我们所有人都带着这个基本前提进行了竞选，即如果你给每个人一个公平的机会，每个人都会做得更好。所以这个我们必须以某种方式让它
great again is a fallacy, it's such a joke. Well you gotta fill them with fear. Because we've never been in better. And please, my next question. Die Hard, is it a Christmas movie? I'm kidding. President Biden, if you could resurrect one person from the past to come hang out in the Oval Office,
再次伟大起来的想法是一个谬论，这真是一个笑话。嗯，你必须用恐惧来填满他们。因为我们从来没有处于更好的状态。拜托，我的下一个问题。《虎胆龙威》，它是圣诞电影吗？我开玩笑的。拜登总统，如果你能让过去的一个人复活来到椭圆形办公室，
you update them on the current state of things, what's their advice? Who would you bring in to give you some perspective on? It'd be hard choice for me between Lincoln, because we are such a divided nation and how he dealt with it, and possibly Roosevelt. But look, I think the country is in much better shape than we're talking about it. Not out of me.
你向他们更新当前的情况，他们的建议是什么？你会带谁进来给你一些视角？对我来说，在林肯和罗斯福之间做出选择会很难，因为我们是一个如此分裂的国家，以及他如何处理这个问题。但看，我认为这个国家的状态比我们谈论的要好得多。不是从我这里。
It is. We have the best economy in the world, the strongest one in the world, period. Okay? Everyone, if you know how China's going to eat our lunch, notice who China's coming to talk to all the time now, right? The idea that Russia was going to eat our lunch. Notice who China's coming to talk to all the time now, right? The idea that Russia was going to... I want to tell you a quote. I got a call from Dr. Kissinger before he died, about 10 days before he died.
确实如此。我们拥有世界上最好的经济，世界上最强大的经济，句号。好吗？每个人，如果你知道中国将如何吃掉我们的午餐，注意现在谁一直在找中国谈话，对吧？认为俄罗斯会吃掉我们的午餐。注意现在谁一直在找中国谈话，对吧？认为俄罗斯会……我想告诉你一个引语。基辛格博士在去世前给我打了个电话，大约在他去世前10天。
And I asked me to give him a call. And I called and he said the following thing. He said, you know, he said, not since Napoleon has Europe not looked over its shoulder at Russia with dread. And then you guys came along, you strengthened NATO, you expanded it, and that's changed. You've changed it all. Well, this guy's changed it all, but he doesn't care. He doesn't care.
他让我给他打个电话。我打了，他说了以下的话。他说，你知道，他说，自拿破仑以来，欧洲还没有像现在这样不再带着恐惧回头看俄罗斯。然后你们来了，你们加强了北约，你们扩大了它，情况改变了。你们改变了一切。嗯，这家伙改变了一切，但他不在乎。他不在乎。
And that's what the rest of the world looks at, is do you have any interest in our concern? And can you imagine us being able to avoid a European war? Can you imagine us, why the hell we set up NATO in the first place? Can you imagine what we're, I mean, there's, it's just, he has no sense of anything. He doesn't believe in anything, we know that, right? There's no. Well, he believes in one thing.
这就是世界其他地方所看到的，你对我们的担忧有任何兴趣吗？你能想象我们能够避免一场欧洲战争吗？你能想象我们，为什么我们当初要建立北约？你能想象我们，我的意思是，这，这只是，他对任何事情都没有感觉。他不相信任何事情，我们知道这一点，对吧？没有。嗯，他相信一件事。
He believes in selling what he's gonna benefit him personally. Right. Well, and I do think that there's one other thing. You were talking about, Jason, social issues versus economic issues. Why is it that sometimes things look good, but people don't feel good all the time? Part of it is, as I said before, things are changing. Folks are nervous, but underneath all the polarization that people are getting through TikTok and social media and cable news, Bill's point about the average person
他相信兜售对他个人有利的东西。对。嗯，我确实认为还有一件事。贾森，你刚才谈到了社会问题与经济问题。为什么有时事情看起来不错，但人们并不总是感觉良好？部分原因是，正如我之前所说，事情正在发生变化。人们很紧张，但在TikTok、社交媒体和有线电视新闻带来的所有两极分化之下，比尔关于普通人
just wanting to do the right thing, they actually don't want folks arguing all the time. They're really not looking for sort of a Death match, you know on every single issue They'd like to see people be treating each other decently right they don't want to go to Walmart and argue with our neighbor About whether they're or if you're a little league right and area center your kids soccer game right and you got the parent next to you you want to talk about kids little league, right, and you're sitting at your kid's soccer game, and you've got the parent next to you, you wanna talk about kids and soccer. And I do think that underneath all this demonization and anger that people make money off of,
只想做正确的事的观点，他们实际上并不想让人们一直争吵。他们真的不是在寻找那种死亡竞赛，你知道，在每一个问题上。他们希望看到人们体面地对待彼此，对吧？他们不想去沃尔玛和我们的邻居争论他们是否……或者如果你在小联盟，或者在孩子的足球比赛中，你旁边有家长，你想谈论孩子的小联盟，对吧，你坐在孩子的足球比赛中，你旁边有家长，你想谈论孩子和足球。我确实认为，在所有这些人们从中赚钱的妖魔化和愤怒之下，
and that gets a lot of clicks, people do want to see some decency right and common sense and I think Joe represents that and his administration represents that and and and if we can Break through You know all of us doing the work of a campaign just to remind folks of What Lincoln called the better? angels of our nature, then I think we're going to be okay.
而且这能获得很多点击量，人们确实希望看到一些体面和常识，我认为乔代表了这一点，他的政府代表了这一点，如果我们能突破，你知道，我们所有人都在做竞选工作，只是为了提醒人们林肯所说的“我们本性中善良的天使”，那么我认为我们会没事的。
But the challenge we've got is anger and resentment and calling people names gets more attention. And we do have to, one thing we do have to, I'm not sure, Jason, that in order to do have to, one thing we do have to, I'm not sure Jason that in order to do the show, the performance you talked about, that it has to be pugilistic, that it has to be hitting the other guy in the nose. It does have to be entertaining.
但我们面临的挑战是愤怒、怨恨和辱骂他人会得到更多关注。我们确实必须，有一件事我们必须，我不确定，贾森，为了做这个节目，你谈到的表演，它必须是好斗的，它必须是打对方的鼻子。它确实必须是有趣的。
You know, I mean, you do have to be able to, you know, build Joe, me, you know, when I'm doing okay, you know, it's about telling stories that people can relate to, because people can't relate to facts and numbers and figures as much as they can relate to stories. And to personal experience. And personal experience.
你知道，我的意思是，你确实必须能够，你知道，建立乔，我，你知道，当我做得还可以时，你知道，这是关于讲述人们能产生共鸣的故事，因为人们对事实、数字和数据的共鸣不如对故事的共鸣多。以及个人经历。和个人经历。
That's what people relate to, and that performing by telling people stories, reminding them who they are, what family means to them, And that performing by telling people stories, reminding them who they are, what family means to them, what it means to struggle and overcome. Joe, what he had to overcome in terms of getting where he was. Bill, a master storyteller talking about what it was like growing up, single mom, Arkansas.
这就是人们产生共鸣的地方，通过讲述故事来表演，提醒人们他们是谁，家庭对他们意味着什么，以及奋斗和克服困难意味着什么。乔，他在达到今天的位置之前必须克服多少困难。比尔，一位讲故事的大师，讲述了他成长过程中的点滴，单亲妈妈，阿肯色州。
And those are the things that really, I think, resonate with people, and if we can get more of that, instead of the kind of name calling that we're seeing out here, I think we'll do okay. Right, right. That's the way you let people know you understand what their concerns are. Look, I mean, think about it.
我认为这些才是真正能引起人们共鸣的事情，如果我们能多做这些，而不是像我们现在看到的这种互相谩骂，我想我们会做得很好。对，没错。这就是你让人们知道你理解他们关切的方式。听着，我的意思是，想想看。
Everybody's gone through some tough times, but one of the, they want, my dad used to have an expression, I swear to God. He said, Joey, a job is about a lot more than a paycheck. It's about your dignity. It's about respect. It's being able to look your kid in the eye and say everything's going to be okay. And there's a shot of it. That's what three of us have tried to do. We've tried to, we're not, if you, look, if you want to be, if you can earn a billion bucks and you do it legally, great. I'm a capitalist, fine. Just start paying your damn taxes. You know what billionaires pay in taxes? By the way, we have just one
每个人都经历过一些艰难时刻，但我父亲过去常说一句口头禅，我发誓。他说，乔伊，工作不仅仅是为了薪水。它关乎你的尊严。它关乎尊重。它关乎能够直视你孩子的眼睛说一切都会好起来的。这就是它的意义所在。这就是我们三个人一直试图做到的。我们试图，我们不是，如果你，听着，如果你想成为，如果你能合法地赚到十亿美金，那很好。我是个资本家，没问题。只要开始缴纳你该死的税款就行。你知道亿万富翁缴纳多少税吗？顺便说一句，我们只有一个
example that you're extreme. We have a thousand billionaires in America right now. If they paid a 25% instead of 8.2% what they pay now, just 25%, it raised $400 million over the next billion dollars over the next 10 years. We could take care of childcare, which increases productivity. We could take care of elder care, which increases productivity. Yeah, let's do it. Well, screw 25, why don't they pay 40? Well, look, here's the deal.
极端的例子。我们现在美国有一千位亿万富翁。如果他们缴纳25%而不是现在缴纳的8.2%，仅仅是25%，未来10年就能筹集到4亿美元。我们可以解决儿童保育问题，这能提高生产力。我们可以解决老年护理问题，这也能提高生产力。是的，让我们做吧。好吧，去他的25%，为什么他们不付40%呢？好吧，听着，情况是这样的。
That's what everyone else is paying. Now who's Canadian? Yeah. That's what I was thinking. No, but I'm just making the point that you don't have to be extreme in anything to get this done. Don't forget that Trump's dad once said,
那是其他人都在支付的比例。现在谁是加拿大人？是的。我刚才就在想这个。不，我只是想说明，你不需要在任何事情上走极端就能完成这件事。别忘了特朗普的父亲曾经说过，
get that family out of 14G. Hey, listen. Listen, if this comes out, and it's helpful at all, is there a chance that the three of us could be on a bill of your designation, President Biden? Maybe a special $250 bill or something? Something like that. With our dumb faces on it.
让那家人离开14G房间。嘿，听着。听着，如果这段录音播出了，而且有一点帮助的话，我们三个人有没有机会出现在你指定的钞票上，拜登总统？也许是一张特别的250美元钞票之类的？类似这样的。上面印着我们愚蠢的脸。
Yeah, I think it should be. Think about it, don't give us an answer. We'll see you at the inauguration. $3 bill. $3 bill. Thank you. Well, I've been called as inauguration. $3 bill. $3 bill. Well I've been called as queer as a $3 bill, but anyway. Honestly, listen, we've taken up way too much of your time. You gentlemen are very, very busy.
是的，我觉得应该这样。想想看，别急着给我们答案。我们在就职典礼上见。3美元钞票。3美元钞票。谢谢。好吧，我曾被称为像3美元钞票一样虚假，但不管怎样。老实说，听着，我们占用你太多时间了。你们几位非常非常忙。
We thank you. Really, really cool. It's just moving to be part of the three of you. Thank you so, so much. Really important. Thank you, guys. We had a great time. Thank you.
我们感谢你们。真的，真的很酷。能成为你们三位的一部分真是令人感动。非常非常感谢。真的很重要。谢谢你们，伙计们。我们玩得很开心。谢谢。
Have fun tonight. All right, guys. Wow. Oh boy. That was cool. That happened right there. I'm very proud of us for keeping it together, keeping it classy. How are you guys feeling about it?
今晚玩得开心。好的，伙计们。哇。天哪。那太酷了。刚才发生的事情。我为我们能保持冷静、保持风度感到非常自豪。你们感觉如何？
That's crazy, right? Yeah, I feel like I'm in good hands, right? When I'm around those guys. Absolutely. Boy. Anyway, that was a real privilege for the three of us. I hope our listeners enjoyed that as much as we did, irrespective of your political affiliation.
那太疯狂了，对吧？是的，我觉得我在好人手中，对吧？当我和那些人在一起时。绝对是。天哪。不管怎样，这对我们三个人来说真的是一种荣幸。我希望我们的听众和我们一样喜欢这次访谈，无论你的政治立场如何。
Being able, you know, three knuckleheads like us sitting across from three leaders of the free world is nothing the three of us ever expected we'd be able to do. So thank you guys as listeners for enabling that. How about the Secret Service people on the way in and on the way out? Sean was disappointed because he had heard, he was having the impression that we were gonna have a visit to the Secret Circus and he thought that that was the thing.
能够，你知道，像我们三个笨蛋一样坐在自由世界的三位领导人对面，是我们三个从未想过能做到的事情。所以感谢你们作为听众促成了这一切。进出时的特勤局人员怎么样？肖恩很失望，因为他听说，他以为我们要去参观“秘密马戏团”（Secret Circus），他以为那是真的。
He thought that there was a secret, yeah. And so he thought. I'm sorry, I bought peanuts. I got like that. And he said he wanted to see bears riding bicycles. I'm like, I could see that at home for free. Hell. Wait, so let me ask you guys, were you nervous?
他以为有一个秘密的，是的。所以他以为。抱歉，我买了花生。我就是那样。他说他想看熊骑自行车。我说，我在家就能免费看到那个。见鬼。等等，让我问问你们，你们紧张吗？
Because at the beginning of it, I remember saying, I thought I'd be more nervous, but because they're so relaxed and I feel like, you know, they just speak so freely, you feel like you connect with them, that the nerves went away a little bit. They're very good at disarming the folks that are sitting across from them.
因为在开始的时候，我记得我说过，我以为我会更紧张，但因为他们太放松了，我觉得，你知道，他们说话如此自由，让你觉得你和他们有联系，所以紧张感稍微消失了一些。他们非常擅长消除坐在他们对面的人的戒心。
They were very chillaxed. I found them to be very chillaxed, and that's how I describe them. But then when I wasn't talking, I was nervous. I was listening to you guys. I gotta say, I felt pretty chillaxed. I know, you know what I mean? If you say it one more time, I'm gonna hang up.
他们非常放松。我发现他们非常放松，这就是我形容他们的方式。但当我没说话的时候，我很紧张。我在听你们说话。我得说，我感觉挺放松的。我知道，你明白我的意思吗？如果你再说一遍，我就挂断电话。
I'm gonna shut the computer. I just want it back. I want it back in the, I want people to start using it. I think it was you that explained to me what the Netflix and chill phrase is. I never knew what the hell that meant. It annoyed me quite a bit. But then, was it you that told me it's code for having sex?
我要关掉电脑。我只是想把它找回来。我想让人们开始使用它。我想是你向我解释了“Netflix and chill”这个短语是什么意思。我从来不知道那到底是什么意思。它让我很烦。但后来，是你告诉我那是发生性关系的暗语吗？
Is that right? Well, I don't know if I wanna get into more like the fact that you're a dad or that we're back in 2017. I don't know which one I wanna hit first. You know what I mean? Yeah. By the way, have you guys heard this band Public Enemy? Fuck me, man. You're killing me.
是这样吗？好吧，我不知道我是该更多地谈论你是个爸爸的事实，还是我们回到了2017年。我不知道我想先谈哪一个。你明白我的意思吗？是的。顺便问一下，你们听过Public Enemy这个乐队吗？去你的，伙计。你快把我搞疯了。
This is a group. You're killing me. I do want to say with the presidents, it was incredible. You know, and I mentioned this too, which was that the one thing that you can't deny, no matter where you are on the sort of political spectrum, if you will, is that under President Biden, the jobs numbers have been incredible. And I think that he has earned the moniker Joe Jobs.
这是一个组合。你快把我搞疯了。我确实想说，和总统们在一起，真是不可思议。你知道，我也提到了这一点，那就是无论你在政治光谱的什么位置，有一点是不可否认的，那就是在拜登总统领导下，就业数据非常惊人。我认为他赢得了“乔就业”（Joe Jobs）这个绰号。
Joe Jobs. He is, to me, he's Joe Jobs. That is great. That's great. Joe Jobs. Yeah. Joey Jobinstein. Sure, sure, sure, yeah.
乔就业。对我来说，他就是乔就业。那太棒了。那太棒了。乔就业。是的。乔伊·就业斯坦。当然，当然，当然，是的。
Whatever you want, Joey, whatever you want. Yeah, Joey Jobs is great. I love that, Joey Jobs., sure. Whatever you want, Joey, whatever you want. Yeah, Joey Jobs is great. I love Joey Jobs. Well, because what? Unemployment is at a 50 year low, right? I think we covered. The economy's at an all time high. It really is.
随你怎么叫，乔伊，随你怎么叫。是的，乔伊就业太棒了。我喜欢那个，乔伊就业。当然。随你怎么叫，乔伊，随你怎么叫。是的，乔伊就业太棒了。我喜欢乔伊就业。好吧，因为什么？失业率处于50年来的最低点，对吧？我想我们涵盖了。经济处于历史最高水平。确实如此。
Meaning, good. Inflation is gonna work itself out, but that's not his fault at all. That was something that, the COVID and the whole, all that other stuff, I'm not smart enough to describe. No, and we never went into that recession that they thought would happen
意思是，很好。通货膨胀会自行解决，但这根本不是他的错。那是，新冠疫情和整个，所有其他事情，我没有足够的智慧去描述。不，我们从来没有陷入他们认为会发生的经济衰退。
and that a lot of that was due to supply chain stuff, issues, et cetera, et cetera. So we're definitely back on, but the one thing that you can't argue with is the jobs. Like it's just irrefutable, right? So again, I don't care where you fall. I'm not saying he's better than your guy or your guy whatever I mean he is but what I'm saying is whether you're Republican or Democrat you need a job and he's he's the guy that's
其中很大一部分是由于供应链问题等等。所以我们肯定恢复了，但有一点是无法反驳的，那就是就业。这简直是无可辩驳的，对吧？所以再说一次，我不在乎你支持谁。我不是说他比你支持的人更好，我的意思是，他是，但我想说的是，无论你是共和党人还是民主党人，你都需要一份工作，而他就是那个
Bring it. Yeah, he's Joe jobs. So you have Joe jobs So you have Obama and Clinton and then we use this one before but it's Go ahead, Sean. And Biden! Biden! Joe Jobs! Smart. Less. Smart.
来吧。是的，他是乔就业。所以你有奥巴马和克林顿，然后我们之前用过这个，但它是，继续吧，肖恩。还有拜登！拜登！乔就业！聪明。少。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Grant Terry. If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。SmartLess是由Rob Armgerve、Bennett Barbicoe和Michael Grant Terry百分之百有机且手工制作的。如果你喜欢SmartLess，现在就可以通过在Wondry应用程序或Apple Podcasts上加入Wondry Plus来提前收听无广告版本。
Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Back in the 90s, Pepsi and Coca-Cola were in a heated race to try and win loyal customers by any means necessary. But when Pepsi launched an ambitious promotion that encouraged people to buy Pepsi and redeem points for prizes, they overlooked their own fine print in a major way. I'm Misha Brown, and I'm the host of Wandery's podcast The Big Flop. Every week, guests join me to chronicle one of the biggest pop culture fails of all time. Like who at Pepsi thought it would be a good idea to advertise that people could earn enough
Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上收听无广告版本。在你离开之前，请通过在Wondry.com/survey填写简短调查告诉我们关于你的信息。在90年代，百事可乐和可口可乐展开了一场激烈的竞赛，试图通过任何必要手段赢得忠实客户。但当百事可乐发起一项雄心勃勃的促销活动，鼓励人们购买百事可乐并兑换奖品积分时，他们严重忽略了自己细则中的内容。我是Misha Brown，我是Wondry播客《The Big Flop》的主持人。每周，嘉宾都会加入我，记录有史以来最大的流行文化失败案例之一。比如百事可乐里是谁觉得宣传人们可以赚取足够的
points to redeem a military jet as a prize? They never imagined somebody might actually try to snag it. But a 23-year-old did. And suddenly, Pepsi owed him a jet. Follow the Big Flop on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to the Big Flop early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
积分来兑换一架军用喷气式飞机作为奖品是个好主意？他们从未想过真的会有人尝试去抢它。但一个23岁的年轻人做到了。突然间，百事可乐欠他一架喷气式飞机。在Wondry应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方关注《The Big Flop》。你现在可以通过加入Wondry Plus提前收听无广告版的《The Big Flop》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。